I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey. Hello. If you have a daughter, you can take her to work today. Yes. It's take your daughter to work day. To Dunder, Mifflin. Season two, episode 18. This one's written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Victor Nellie Jr. Victor Nellie. Second one he's directed. Yes. Prolific TV director. He's fantastic. We really liked him. He was so nice. Should
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嘿。你好。如果你有女儿，今天你可以带她去上班。是的。今天是带女儿上班日。去丹德米夫林。第二季，第18集。这一集由明迪·卡林编剧，维克托·内利二世执导。维克托·内利。这是他执导的第二集。是的。高产的电视剧导演。他太棒了。我们真的很喜欢他。他太友善了。应该
I start with a summary? Jenna, you know that's how you start. I know. Just do it. I should just do it in order. I like every week, though, that you ask me. Every week you're like, should I start with a summary? Like what if I was like, no, not today, lady. What would I do? I don't know. Would I listen to you or would I just do it anyway? You'd probably be deer in headlights. You know what? Try it some week and we'll see. Okay, I will. But not this week. You told me to do it. Do it. Here I go. In this episode, the Dunder, Mifflin employees bring their daughters to work for the day. Stanley brings his teenage daughter who starts crushing on Ryan. I mean, she's just a version of Mindy, right? A little
我从剧情概要开始吗？珍娜，你知道你一向都是这么开始的。我知道。那就开始吧。我应该按顺序来。不过我喜欢你每周都问我。每周你都会问，我要从剧情概要开始吗？就好像我说“不，今天不行，女士”会怎么样。我会怎么做？我不知道。我是会听你的，还是不管怎样都会直接开始？你可能会像面对车灯的鹿一样不知所措。你知道吗？有周你试试看，我们拭目以待。好吧，我会的。但不是这周。你让我开始的。那就开始。我来了。在这一集里，丹德米夫林的员工们把女儿带到公司上班。斯坦利带了他十几岁的女儿，她开始对莱恩产生了好感。我的意思是，她简直就是明迪的翻版，对吧？有点
bit. A little bit. What is it about Ryan? The ladies love Ryan. I know. Kevin brings his fiance's daughter. Right. Meredith brings her son and Toby brings his kind of shy five-year-old daughter who ends up bonding with Michael. Also in this episode, Pam makes it her mission to befriend just one kid. Just one. Yeah, we learned that Pam is not good with kids. Apparently not. All right, should we do our Fast Facts? Why are you asking me? Because that's part of it. Yes, do them. Part of doing the Fast Facts is me asking you if I should do the Fast Facts. Yes, Jenna, you should do your Fast Facts. Fast Facts number one. We got a lot of questions about the kids in this episode. So let's break them down one by one. Stanley
像。有点像。莱恩到底有什么魅力？女士们都爱莱恩。我知道。凯文带了他未婚妻的女儿。没错。梅雷迪思带了她的儿子，托比带了他有点害羞的五岁女儿，她最后和迈克尔打成一片。这一集里，帕姆的任务是和仅仅一个孩子交朋友。仅仅一个。是的，我们了解到帕姆不擅长应付小孩。显然是这样。好了，我们该公布“快速冷知识”了吗？你为什么问我？因为那是流程的一部分。是的，讲吧。讲快速冷知识的一部分就是我问你应不应该讲快速冷知识。是的，珍娜，你应该讲你的快速冷知识。快速冷知识第一条。我们收到了很多关于这一集里孩子们的提问。所以让我们逐一剖析他们。斯坦利
Stoddermalissa was played by Jazz Ray Cole. Okay. And she is a professional actress. No relation to anyone on the show. We hired her. She was also on the sitcom My Wife and Kids. When she shot this episode, she was 17 or 18 years old. So her birthday is in February. And I think that's right around the time we were shooting. And I have this memory of her telling me that she had just turned 18. Aw. When I first came to Los Angeles, I was in my 20s, but I looked like I was a teenager. Right. And so I had this special agent who would send me out for roles to play high school kids. Because when you have a kid on a set, they have very limited work hours. They have child hours, according to the union rules.
的女儿梅丽莎由爵士·雷·科尔饰演。好的。她是一位专业演员。跟剧组任何人都没有亲戚关系。是我们雇她的。她还出演过情景喜剧《我的老婆和孩子》。她拍这一集的时候，大概17或18岁。所以她的生日在二月。我想那大概就是我们拍摄的时候。我记忆中她告诉我她刚满18岁。啊。我刚来洛杉矶时，我二十多岁，但我看起来像个青少年。没错。所以我有一个专属经纪人，会派我去试镜高中生的角色。因为当你在片场有儿童演员时，他们的工作时间非常有限。根据工会规则，他们有儿童工作时长限制。
And so they can't work as long of days. They have to take these breaks. There has to be a tutor who teaches them school stuff. So if you look older than 18, but you can play a kid, this is like a little niche market. I was in 90210. Oh my gosh, Angela. No, you were not. I was in 90210. And I didn't have lines. My biggest moment, though, was when I played Tori Spelling's sorority sister. Uh-huh. And we were collecting votes. I think they were going to vote some girl out of the sorority. And I collected the votes and I had to hand them to Tori. Whoa. Yes. So I remember, I remember it like it was kind of cool if you, you know, could get parts like that because you could work longer hours
所以他们不能工作那么长时间。他们必须休息。必须有家教教他们学校的功课。所以如果你看起来比18岁大，但又能演小孩，这就是一个小众市场。我演过《飞越比弗利》。哦天哪，安吉拉。才没有。我演过《飞越比弗利》。而且我没有台词。不过我最高光的时刻，是我扮演托莉·斯elling的姐妹会姐妹。嗯哼。我们在收集选票。我想他们要投票把某个女孩赶出姐妹会。我收集了选票，不得不交给托莉。哇。是的。所以我记得，那种感觉就像，如果你，你知道，能得到这样的角色会很酷，因为你可以工作更长时间
and you were older playing younger. I got to be in the movie Pleasantville with Toby McGuire and Reese Witherspoon. That's a good one. Uh-huh. And I got to work a whole week, which is really exciting. I was just a featured extra. Me too. When I was the sorority sister, I was the featured extra. Yes. I was a featured extra in Pleasantville because I was over 18 to play under. Yeah. Oh my gosh. I love that. Toby's daughter, Sasha was played by Delaney Ruth Farrell. Now here's a little interesting tidbit about her. She was the daughter of our set dresser, Sean Farrell. Aw. So you maybe remember, we had an establishing shot of Toby's desk a while ago where he explains that he's divorced and he has a
而且你年龄较大却在演年轻人。我有幸参演了电影《欢乐谷》，搭档托比·马奎尔和瑞茜·威瑟斯彭。那是个不错的电影。嗯哼。我工作了整整一周，这真的让人兴奋。我只是个特约群演。我也是。当我演姐妹会成员时，我就是个特约群演。是的。我是《欢乐谷》里的特约群演，因为我超过18岁却在演比自己小的人。是的。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。托比的女儿萨莎由黛兰妮·露丝·法尔饰演。这里有一个关于她的有趣小花絮。她是我们的布景师肖恩·法尔的女儿。啊。所以你可能还记得，不久前我们有一个托比办公桌的建立镜头，他在镜头里解释说他离婚了，他有一个
daughter and there is a picture of a little blonde girl. He says this is Sasha. That picture was placed there by Sean of his daughter. So when it came time to do this episode, we kind of had to use her. Wait. So did Sean just sort of make that happen? Yeah. Sean just put a picture of his daughter on Toby's desk. Well, she's very cute. So cute. And she was so good. She did great. Not an actress, just daughter of our set dresser. Yeah. And she's going to come back again in Family Portrait Day. Okay. So now Meredith's son. Meredith's son is hard to say. Meredith's son. You guys, Jenna has tried it three times. I have. Meredith's son. Meredith's son. Palmer was played by Spencer Daniels. No relation to Greg Daniels. Nope.
女儿，桌上有一张金发小女孩的照片。他说这是萨莎。那张照片是肖恩放上去的，照片里是他的女儿。所以当要拍这一集时，我们差不多就必须用她了。等等。所以肖恩就这么把这事儿办成了？是的。肖恩只是把一张他女儿的照片放在了托比的桌上。好吧，她太可爱了。太可爱了。而且她表现得很好。她干得真棒。不是演员，只是我们布景师的女儿。是的。而且她还会再回来，在《全家福日》那一集。好的。现在是梅雷迪思的儿子。梅雷迪思的儿子这名字真拗口。梅雷迪思的儿子。你们看，珍娜已经试了三次了。我确实试了。梅雷迪思的儿子。梅雷迪思的儿子。
Wikipedia, you're wrong. Okay. Did you hear us? Fix it. Okay. Maybe that was somewhere else. I read that. Dunderpedia. Maybe it was Dunder. One of the pedias is saying that Spencer Daniels is Greg Daniels' son. He is not. Not the case. Now, Spencer is also going to come back in Season 8, Episode 24, Family Portrait Day. Fan question from Curly Hair Tess and Hannah Bursell and Lisa Farr and many others. Was Meredith's son played by the same actor when he came back as the stripper for Angela's Bachelorette Party in Season 9? We'll get there, but that's one of the most uncomfortable moments of my life. Yes. It's the same actor. Yes. Oh, God. Yes. Yes. Same guy and he's still acting today.
帕尔默由斯宾塞·丹尼尔斯饰演。跟格雷格·丹尼尔斯没有亲戚关系。没有。维基百科，你搞错了。好吧。你们听到了吗？修正一下。好吧。也许那是别的地方的说法。我读到的。丹德百科。也许是丹德。其中一个百科说斯宾塞·丹尼尔斯是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的儿子。他不是。根本不是这回事。现在，斯宾塞还会在第八季第二十四集《全家福日》中回归。来自卷发苔丝、汉娜·伯塞尔、莉萨·法尔以及许多其他人的粉丝提问。当梅雷迪思的儿子在第九季回归饰演安吉拉单身派对的脱衣舞男时，是由同一个演员扮演的吗？我们后面会讲到，但那是这辈子最尴尬的时刻之一。是的。是同一个演员。没错。天哪。是的。是的。
So he is a professional actor. That wasn't for him as a person. It was just that. Right. It's just a young boy. We met him when he was a boy and then when he was a man, he stripped at your fictional Bachelorette Party. I know. Okay. Okay. And then finally, there was Kevin's fiance's daughter, Abby, who was played by Hailey Daniels, who is Greg Daniels' daughter. Yes. Hailey is so, so sweet. Yeah. And she did a great job. She's so good. Not an actor. Not an actor. She did such a great job. She had to be very deadpan and I thought she was hilarious. Fast fact number two, a lot of people ask, what was it like to do an episode with all these kids around? Now, what did you remember about that, Ange? Well, I mean, Hailey was
同一个人，他现在还在演戏。所以他是个专业演员。这并不是为他个人安排的。只是剧情需要。没错。他只是个年轻男孩。我们认识他时他还是个男孩，然后当他长大成人的时候，他在你虚构的单身派对上跳了脱衣舞。我知道。好的。好的。最后，还有凯文未婚妻的女儿艾比，由海莉·丹尼尔斯饰演，她就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的女儿。是的。海莉非常非常甜美。是的。而且她表现得很出色。她太棒了。不是演员。不是演员。她表现得太棒了。她必须表现得非常冷面搞笑，我觉得她滑稽极了。快速冷知识第二条，很多人问，和这么多小孩子一起拍戏是什么体验？那么，安吉，你对那有什么记忆吗？嗯，我的意思是，海莉经常
in our little accounting nook quite a bit and I just wanted to make sure she was good. Yeah. I think I just want to make sure she was like, do you, all right, do you need to go to the bathroom? Do you have snacks? I just sort of became that person. Yeah. But obviously, when kids are in an adult work environment, you do change your behavior. Or you should. Sorry. I remember we got a little lecture about it. Yeah. Oh, we got a little talking to. We got a little talking to actually. At the beginning of filming. Yeah. At the beginning of filming, just like, Hey guys, there's going to be kids on set. Let's just mind our manners today. And actually, when Michael and you have that scene in the cold open where you're
待在我们那个小会计角落里，我只是想确保她一切都好。是的。我想我只是想确保她感觉，你，好吧，你需要去洗手间吗？你有零食吗？我差不多就成了那种人。是的。但很明显，当孩子们来到成人的工作环境时，你的行为确实会发生改变。或者说理应如此。抱歉。我记得我们为此听了一小场讲座。是的。哦，我们被稍微说教了一下。其实我们确实被稍微说教了一下。在拍摄开始的时候。是的。在拍摄开始时，就像是，嘿大家，片场会有小孩子。今天让我们注意举止。事实上，当迈克尔和你在冷场开场里有那场戏，你当时说
like, Michael, I talked to you about this. That actually reminded me of whenever we had people visiting the set. Yeah. Whenever, sometimes families would visit the set. They would win like some type of visit and a whole family would come. And a lot of times our AD, Kelly Cantley would be like, Hey, everyone heads up, young children. Keep it G rated. Not that we were like a body group, but you know, it's like a group of adults all day. I feel like when there weren't kids around, though, there was quite a bit of cursing. There were. Yes, that's true. So there were adult words that there were adult words. But besides that, we weren't. Yeah. Super like weird or inappropriate or anything. No, but our scripts were half
就像，迈克尔，我跟你聊过这个。那其实让我想起了每当有访客来片场的时候。对啊。每当，有时会有家属来片场。他们会赢那种参观机会，然后全家人都会来。很多时候我们的副导演凯利·坎特利会说，嘿，大家注意，有小孩子。保持在G级（大众级）。倒不是说我们是个什么成人社群，但你知道，一整天都是一群成年人在那。我觉得只要没有小孩子在，大家其实还是会骂挺多脏话的。确实会。对，没错。所以会有成年人的词汇，确实会有成年人的词汇。不过除此之外，我们倒也没有。对。超级奇怪或不恰当什么的。没有，但我们的剧本有一半
the time. That's true. Half the time there were things that were said within the context of a script where I'm like, Oh, yeah, that's true. Okay. All right. Fast fact number three, this was sent in by a fan. I loved this. Thank you so much, Kelly Nudo. She tipped me off to the fact that Fundle Bundle, you know, the little TV program that Michael was on as a child in this episode, it was inspired by a real local children's program in Scranton called The Land of Hatchimalatchee. Oh my Lord. I love that. Yes. It was a little program for kids that started in the fifties. It ran for almost 25 years. Local, local Scranton. Yes. It featured songs and appearances by kids just like our version. It was originally
时间是这样。没错。有一半时间，剧本里说的话是在那种语境下，我会觉得，哦，对，没错。好吧。第三个快讯，这是由粉丝发来的。我超爱这个。非常感谢凯利·努多。她提醒了我，你知道的，迈克尔小时候在这集里上过的那个小电视节目《杂耍包》（Fundle Bundle），它是受到斯克兰顿当地一个真实儿童节目的启发，那个节目叫《哈奇马拉奇乐园》（The Land of Hatchimalatchee）。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。是的。那是一个从五十年代开始的儿童小节目。播了将近25年。本地的，斯克兰顿本地的。对。它有歌曲，还有小孩子的登场，就像我们的版本一样。它最初是由
hosted by a woman named Nancy Berg, who was referred to as Miss Nancy. And then it was hosted by Miss Judy, who was played by Lois Burns. I don't know why they called her Miss Judy when her name was Lois, but they did. And of course, in our version, we had Miss Trudy, who was played by actress Sue Nelson. And Edward R. Meow. Yes. But this was really sweet. Lois, who played Miss Judy, was interviewed recently about her time on The Land of Hatchimalatchee. And she said, Hatchimalatchee. Hatchimalatchee. Sorry. It just makes me laugh. I know. Okay. What did she say about The Land of Hatchimalatchee? She said that their goal was to make sure that every kid knew they were important. Aw. I love that. I love that little tidbit.
一个名叫南希·伯格的女士主持的，大家称她为南希小姐。后来由洛伊丝·伯恩斯饰演的朱迪小姐主持。我不知道为什么她名字叫洛伊丝，却非要叫她朱迪小姐，但他们就是这么叫的。当然，在我们的版本里，我们有由演员苏·尼尔森饰演的特鲁迪小姐。还有喵喵爱德华。对。但这真的很温馨。饰演朱迪小姐的洛伊丝最近接受了关于她在《哈奇马拉奇乐园》度过的那段时光的采访。她说，哈奇马拉奇。哈奇马拉奇。抱歉。我一想到就想笑。我懂。好吧，她是怎么评价《哈奇马拉奇乐园》的？她说他们的目标是确保每个孩子都知道自己很重要。啊。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢这个小八卦了。
Thank you, Kelly, for writing in, because that is like, I don't even know how we would find that. No, that's so great. Thank you. That's not on any of the websites that I usually go to for research. For the deep dive. Yeah. All right. So thank you. She's over on Office Ladies Pod. Over on our Insta. She sent me a message. Oh, that's so cool. Thanks. All right. Those were some really good fast facts, lady. High five. Oh, high five me. That was Jenna and I high-fiving. It was. It's kind of awkward because we have to reach across the table and do microphones. And I always worry about your cards. Don't mess up my cards, lady. Don't mess up your cards. All right. Let's take a break and come back and get
谢谢凯利写信来，因为这就像是，我甚至不知道我们该怎么找到这个。不，这太棒了。谢谢。这在我平时做研究的任何网站上都找不到。为了深度挖掘。对。好吧，所以谢谢。她在Office Ladies Pod。在我们的Ins上。她给我发了一条消息。哦，太酷了。谢谢。好吧，女士们，这些都是非常棒的快讯。击个掌。哦，跟我击个掌。那是詹娜和我击掌。确实是。有点尴尬，因为我们得够着桌子还要避开麦克风。我总是担心你的卡片。别弄乱我的卡片，女士。别弄乱你的卡片。好吧。我们休息一下，回来然后进入
into this episode. Yeah. All right, we're back. Let's start breaking down this episode. We open with a Pam talking head. Yeah. She explains that it's take your daughter to work day. And she says, I'm not actually great with kids, but I want to get better because I'm getting married. So she's going to put out lots of extra candy on her desk. Lots of candy. She got like a potted plant. Did you see that? That's like a last minute store crap. There's like all of a sudden a plant. No, I didn't notice that. I have a little thing for my background pals. All right. At nine seconds, freeze frame. You're going to see over your shoulder. It's on the accounting side. Okay. The Uncle Sam. Do you remember
这集的内容。好的，我们回来了。开始剖析这一集。开场是一个帕姆的单人采访。对。她解释说今天是“带女儿上班日”。她说，我其实不太擅长跟小孩子相处，但我想变得更好，因为我要结婚了。所以她打算在办公桌上摆超多额外的糖果。超多糖果。她还弄了一盆绿植。你看到了吗？那就像是临急抱佛脚买的店里的破烂。突然就多了一盆植物。不，我没注意到。我为我背景里的小伙伴准备了小物件。好吧。在9秒处，定格。你会看到在你的肩膀上方。在会计部那边。好的。山姆大叔。你还记得
the Uncle Sam? Oh yeah. Why did we have that guy? It was a doll of Uncle Sam. Yeah. He had the fourth of July hat on. He had a flag. You could hit a button and I think he would play Yankee Doodle Dandy or something. Right. I don't know. It sat there. When did he show up from the beginning? I think he's there from the beginning. I mean, I have a memory of him because like I would turn around to go and talk to you. He's what I would pass first. So the first time I turned around, I was like, Oh God, history of Uncle Sam is a common national personification of the US federal government. According to legend, it came into use during the war of 1812 and was supposedly named for Samuel Wilson. Who
那个山姆大叔吗？哦对。我们为什么会有那个家伙？那是一个山姆大叔的玩偶。对。他戴着独立日的帽子。他拿着一面旗子。你可以按一个按钮，我想他会播放《洋基歌》或者什么的。对吧。不管怎样，他就摆在那。他是什么时候出现的，从一开始就在吗？我觉得他从一开始就在。我的意思是，我对他的记忆是因为我每次转身去跟你说话。他是第一个我会经过的东西。所以第一次我转身的时候，我就想，哦天哪，山姆大叔的历史是美国联邦政府的一个常见的国家拟人化形象。根据传说，它在1812年战争期间开始使用，据说是以塞缪尔·威尔逊的名字命名的。是谁
was Samuel Wilson? Well, I'll click on him. I'll tell you. Where are you reading this? It's Wikipedia. Wikipedia. Samuel Wilson was a meat packer from Troy, New York, whose name is purportedly the source of the personification of the United States. Uncle Sam kind of looks like it's going in a circle. It is going in a circle. I need to know more about me packer Sam. Meat packer Sam. Anyway, that's Uncle Sam. He sat over my shoulder for nine years. I think I'm going to spend more time on that after the podcast is over. So if you want more Uncle Sam facts, I might bring them to our candy bag. Okay. Bring them to the candy bag. So I noticed something for kind of the detail folks at 21 seconds. The candy on Pam's
是塞缪尔·威尔逊？好吧，我点进去看看。我来告诉你。你在哪里看这个？维基百科。维基百科。塞缪尔·威尔逊是来自纽约州特洛伊市的一个肉类打包商，他的名字据说是美国拟人化形象的来源。山姆大叔看起来像是在转圈。它确实在转圈。我需要了解更多关于肉类打包商山姆的事。肉类打包商山姆。不管怎样，那就是山姆大叔。他在我肩膀后面坐了九年。我想我会在播客结束后花更多时间研究这个。所以如果你想要更多关于山姆大叔的事实，我可能会把它们带到我们的糖果袋里。好的。带到糖果袋里。所以我为细节控们注意到了一件事，在21秒处。帕姆桌上的糖果
desk is suckers and lifesavers. Lollipop things. Yeah. It pretty much stays that way. However, in the previous shot at 10 seconds, there's a bowl of lemon drops, a bowl of starburst and a candy dish full of jelly beans. And then those are gone. And then there's lollipops. Yeah. Candy continuity. Candy continuity. What happened? And then I hold up bags of even more candy, which is none of those things. It's like Jolly Ranchers. I know. Fan question from Michelle Mange. Did Jenna get to decide what candy was sitting at reception? No. I'm going to say no. They just gave it to me. But she also wants to know how often did you guys eat it? A lot. I ate a ton of that candy all the time. I would get sick. People would
是棒棒糖和救生圈糖。棒棒糖类的东西。对。基本上一直都是这样。然而，在前面10秒处的镜头里，有一碗柠檬糖，一碗星爆糖，还有一个装满果冻豆的糖果盘。然后那些都没了。变成了棒棒糖。对。糖果连贯性。糖果连贯性。怎么回事？然后我举起了更多糖果的袋子，根本不是那些东西。就像是彩虹糖。我知道。来自米歇尔·曼格的粉丝提问。詹娜能决定前台摆什么糖果吗？不。我得说不能。他们直接给我的。但她还想知道你们多久吃一次？很多。我一直在吃成吨的那种糖果。我都吃吐了。人们会
walk up and you would think they were coming to talk to you, but they were just coming for candy. It's true. I remember you would sometimes be like, Oh, hey. And then it was just like digging in the candy bowl. I don't remember you eating a lot of it. Do you have a sweet tooth? I don't think of you as having a candy sweet tooth. No, no, I don't. Yep. We're different that way. We're different. I do. All right. So now Michael comes out of his office and Pam explains that he cannot be nasty today because kids are coming. Names Pam, Miss Beasley, if you're nasty. Oh, I'm sorry. Are you having a wardrobe malfunction? Janet Jackson, you're like, no, stop it. Shut it down, Michael. Shut it down. So Michael
走过来，你会以为他们是来找你谈事情的，但他们其实只是来拿糖果的。确实。我记得你有时会说，哦，嘿。然后就只是在糖果碗里掏啊掏。我不记得你吃了很多。你喜欢吃甜食吗？我不觉得你是个爱吃糖果甜食的人。不，不，我不吃。对。我们在这方面不一样。我们不一样。我喜欢。好吧。现在迈克尔从办公室出来了，帕姆解释说他今天不能那么讨人厌，因为小孩子们要来。帕姆点名了，如果你觉得讨厌，那我就叫比斯利小姐。哦，抱歉。你遇到服装故障了吗？珍妮·杰克逊，你就像是，不，住手。关掉它，迈克尔。关掉它。所以迈克尔
is very annoyed. He has a talking head. He says, why is he going to be held back today? He is like Eddie Murphy and Raw. He is HBO. No limits. No limits. And now we're asking him to be Eddie Murphy and Daddy Daycare. No. I mean, can you, why are we doing this to him? I know. He, I mean, I love that he thinks of as his workplace, it's like a place where R rated content should be. That's, that's where it happens is at work. He's like a human resource's nightmare. He is. So Pam convinces Michael to welcome the kids. He comes out into the bullpen. He tries to welcome them. I don't know. He, he really is not into it. He's not into it, but he tries to compare it like, hmm, let me, let me put this in kidspeak.
非常烦躁。他有一个单人采访。他说，为什么他今天要被束缚住？他就像粗俗说唱里的埃迪·墨菲。他是HBO频道。没有限制。没有限制。而现在我们却要求他成为《奶爸别动队》里的埃迪·墨菲。不。我是说，难道你，我们为什么要这样对他的？我知道。他，我的意思是，我喜欢他把他的工作场所当作是一个应该出现R级内容的地方。那就是，那就是工作时发生的事情。他简直是人力资源部门的噩梦。他确实是。所以帕姆说服迈克尔去欢迎孩子们。他来到大办公区。他试着欢迎他们。我不知道，他，他其实一点也不想应付。他一点也不想，但他试着去比喻，嗯，让，让我用小孩子的话来表达。
Oh, I should compare myself to a superhero. And so he's like, I'm like the, you know, I'm, I'm like Superman and Gotham city. And it's the one time like it, this happens so rarely when Jim and Dwight are both on the same page. They're like, that's Batman. And he's like, fine. I'm Aquaman. But it's like Jim and Dwight were actually like together it's true one moment for that one moment to correct Michael. Yeah. Okay. Can we just talk about how cute the little girl that plays Sasha is? Yeah. And when Paul as Toby walks through the kitchen and then Dwight's like, hello tiny one. You are the future. Like just Dwight's idea and like how he sees children. It just made me laugh. I think Toby seems
哦，我应该把自己比作超级英雄。所以他就说，我像那个，你知道的，我就像哥谭市的蝙蝠侠。不对，我是超人。而这是绝无仅有的一次，这种情况太罕见了，吉姆和德怀特居然看法完全一致。他们异口同声地说，那是蝙蝠侠。然后他说，好吧。我是海王。但就像吉姆和德怀特居然真的站在一起了，确实为了那一刻为了纠正迈克尔。对。好吧。我们能聊聊扮演萨莎的小女孩有多可爱吗？对啊。当保罗饰演的托比穿过厨房，然后德怀特说，你好，小不点。你是未来。就像德怀特对孩子的想法以及他是怎么看待他们的。真的逗笑我了。我觉得托比在这集里看起来
like a really good father in this episode. I do too. Yeah. He has the most kind of. He's gentle and parental instincts of all the people that we see parenting in this episode. I agree. I think Toby's a great dad. He might be a little sad, but he's a great dad. So now we go to the scene in accounting where Kevin is explaining his file cabinet to Abby. Oh man. She's thrilled. She's thrilled. I mean, you know, he's showing her the file cabinet, but there is a giant vat of M&Ms. Yeah. Like why doesn't he just say he wants some M&Ms? At two minutes 30 seconds, we had a fan catch. Okay. Fayelle123 says Angela has a dog photo on her side of the partition. Angela, she is not the only person who noticed
像个非常好的父亲。我也这么觉得。对。他有着所有在这集里我们看到的为人父母的人当中最那种。他有着温柔的父母本能。我同意。我觉得托比是个好爸爸。他可能有点悲伤，但他是个好爸爸。所以现在我们来到会计部的场景，凯文正在向艾比解释他的文件柜。天哪。她太兴奋了。她太兴奋了。我是说，你知道的，他在向她展示文件柜，但旁边有一大缸M&M豆。对。为什么他不直接说他想要一些M&M豆呢？在2分30秒时，我们有一个粉丝抓包。好吧。法耶123说安吉拉的隔板上贴了一张狗的照片。安吉拉，她不是唯一一个注意到
this. Michelle Sexton also noticed we got two emails about this dog poster on your partition. Michelle wants to know what does the sign say? I tried to look at it and I couldn't tell what it says. Okay. Well, actually there's a great screen grab of it at 44 seconds. Oh, okay. The dog is actually holding up a sign and it says, we'll love for food. Oh, and I think it's like an adoption or like food donation or something for animals. Do you remember this going up? Why did it all of a sudden appear on your side of the partition? Yeah. It wasn't normally there. And I will tell you guys this. I don't know specifically why this one went up at that moment, but I can tell you sometimes Matt Sohn, our B camera
这一点的人。米歇尔·塞克顿也注意到了，我们收到了两封关于你隔板上这张狗的海报的邮件。米歇尔想知道海报上写的是什么。我试着看了，但我看不出来写的是什么。好吧。嗯，其实在44秒处有一个很好的截屏。哦，好的。那只狗其实举着一个牌子，上面写着，为食物求爱。哦，我觉得这就像是一个领养或者是某种动物的食物捐赠。你还记得这个贴上去吗？为什么它突然出现在你隔板的那一侧？对。它平时不在那。我要告诉你们的是，我不知道具体为什么这个在那个时刻贴上去，但我可以告诉你们，有时马特·索恩，我们的B机
operator or Randall Einhorn, A camera would need to be shooting and accounting and they were quite a bit for this episode. And that glass partition would make a glare. Okay. And so sometimes they would strategically put a little piece of paper of some kind on the glass partition to sort of block the bounce of that glare. Oh, so that they wouldn't get their own reflection on the glass? Yeah. And so they did that sometimes. So all of a sudden I'd sit down to do a scene and I'd be like, what is that? Where are all these papers? Yeah. And it would be to sort of block that glare and them being able to see the camera or the boom. Oh my gosh. So the dog paper was a glare blocker. I think the way they
摄像师，或者是兰德尔·艾因霍恩，A摄影师需要在会计部拍摄，而这集里他们拍了很多。那块玻璃隔板会产生反光。好吧。所以有时他们会有策略地在玻璃隔板上贴一小张某种纸，用来挡住反光的反射。哦，这样玻璃上就不会反射出他们自己的倒影了？对。所以他们有时会这么做。因此我常常坐下来准备拍一场戏，然后就会想，那是什么？这些纸都是哪来的？对。这其实是为了挡住反光，以及让他们看不到摄像机或者收音杆。噢天哪！所以那张狗的纸是个防反光板。我觉得他们
were shooting to catch Abby through the partition and Kevin, there was a glare. And so they put that up. They would often do that. And then that's when I would have random signs on the partition. And you know that Kevin and I, I've said this before of everywhere in the bullpen, we're the only desk pod with a partition. Yes. And you know, my backstory for this is I think Angela Martin requested it because Kevin's disgusting. Well, next we move to Kevin's talking head where he just says he really hopes that Abby doesn't look on his computer. Why is Kevin such a perv? This is the second time he's worried about what's on his computer. I mean, Kevin, did you learn nothing after email surveillance?
拍摄时为了透过隔板拍到艾比和凯文，会有反光。所以他们把它贴上了。他们经常这样做。然后那时我的隔板上就会有一些随机的牌子。而且你们知道凯文和我，我以前说过，在大办公区的各个地方，我们是唯一一个带有隔板的桌子。是的。你们知道我对此的背景设定吗，我认为安吉拉·马丁要求这样是因为凯文太恶心了。好吧，接下来我们来到凯文的单人采访，他在采访中说他真的希望艾比不要看他的电脑。为什么凯文这么色？这是他第二次担心他电脑里的东西了。我是说，凯文，你在电子邮件监控事件之后什么都没学到吗？
I know, but you didn't scrub your computer after that. Also Kevin, just stop being gross. All right. So now Stanley introduces Michael to his daughter, Melissa. Oh man. She's wearing some headphones. Michael says, wow, how do we explain what Michael says? He says she's a stone cold fox. Yeah. And to keep the frat boys away from her. And then she says, I'm in eighth grade. Yeah. Oh, she's a middle schooler. Oh, Michael. That was really awkward. This moves us into Michael's talking head where he says, this is a quote that a lot of people emailed about. He says, it's not the children make me uncomfortable. It's just why be a dad when you can be a fun uncle. And a lot of people thought that this was a continuity
我知道，但你事后没有清理你的电脑啊。还有凯文，别再那么恶心了。好吧。所以现在斯坦利把迈克尔介绍给他的女儿梅丽莎。天哪。她戴着耳机。迈克尔说，哇，我们该怎么解释迈克尔说的话呢？他说她是个冷艳美女。对。还要防着那些大学兄弟会的人接近她。然后她说，我上八年级。对。哦，她是个初中生。哦，迈克尔。这真的太尴尬了。这就引出了迈克尔的单人采访，他说，这是很多人发邮件提到的一句话。他说，不是小孩子们让我感到不舒服，只是既然能当个有趣的叔叔，为什么非要当爸爸呢。很多人认为这是一个连续性
error because we've heard so much about how Michael wants a family and wants to have kids. And they were saying, why does Michael say that he doesn't want to be a dad? Oh, no. He's not saying that. He's compensating for the fact that he's not a dad. He's just giving himself a pep talk. Yeah. All Michael wants to do is have a family. For sure. For sure. And I think in this moment, he's just like trying to put a good spin on where his life is at for himself. I think so too. Yeah. I think so too. It kind of made me sad because you know, that's not really where his heart's at. Oh, well, wait, I know. I mean, I sobbed twice during this episode. We'll get to that at three minutes, 31 seconds. We meet Jake,
错误，因为我们听过太多关于迈克尔多么想要一个家庭、想要生孩子的事。他们在说，为什么迈克尔会说他不想当爸爸？哦，不。他不是那个意思。他是在为自己不是个父亲而进行心理补偿。他只是在给自己加油打气。对。迈克尔唯一想做的事就是拥有一个家庭。肯定的。肯定的。而且我觉得在这个时刻，他只是试图为自己当前的生活状态找一个好的说辞。我也这么觉得。对。我也这么觉得。这让我觉得有点难过，因为你知道的，那并不是他内心真正的想法。哦，好吧，等一下，我知道。我是说，在这集里我哭了两次。我们一会儿会讲到那。在3分31秒，我们遇到了杰克，
Meredith son. Yeah. Meredith son. Meredith son. A hard thing to say. He was suspended from school. He's kind of a rascal. That's a nice way to put it. I know. I wrote a different word. It rhymes with shmashmo. But yeah, he's just not nice. And I'm like, I mean, he's like throwing things at people. Yeah. He's like a name. I know. His shirt. Did you see what his shirt says? Yes. It says something like I have already forgotten your name. Yes. That's what it says. I mean, Meredith. Meredith. Why are you letting him walk around with that shirt on? Yeah. Okay. So the next scene I love, it's three minutes, 44 seconds. We're in the conference room. We're setting up for something. It looks like there might be a
梅丽莎的儿子。对。梅丽莎的儿子。梅丽莎的儿子。真是个难念的名字。他被学校停学了。他简直是个淘气鬼。这话说得真委婉。我知道。我写了另一个词。押韵于“混蛋”。但总之，他就是很不讨人喜欢。我觉得，我的意思是，他到处扔东西。对。他像个名字。我知道。他的衬衫。你看到他的衬衫上写的是什么了吗？看到了。上面写着类似“我已经忘了你的名字”之类的话。是的。就是那样写的。我是说，梅丽莎。梅丽莎。你为什么让他穿着那件衬衫到处走？对。好吧。接下来的这个场景我超爱，在3分44秒。我们在会议室里。我们在为某事做准备。
party aspect to this day. It's you, Kelly and Ryan. Kelly's helping me put a tablecloth on the conference room table. I just want to say, remember in the Christmas episode when you did not helping you put it on? Yeah. Kelly is also not really helping you put it on. Anytime there's a party, I totally relate to Angela because you guys are a bunch of jerks that don't really help. You know what? I have a feeling that every time we try to help you with that tablecloth, you yell at us. I don't think so. And that's why we're not helping you with it. I don't think so. You probably nitpick how we're doing it. That's what I, why does no one help you with the tablecloth? Because you're a bunch of
看来这一天可能会有一个派对环节。是你、凯利和瑞恩。凯利在帮我给会议室的桌子铺桌布。我只想说，还记得圣诞节那集里你也没有帮我铺桌布吗？对。凯利其实也没有真正帮你铺。每当有派对的时候，我完全能理解安吉拉，因为你们这群混蛋其实都没怎么帮忙。你知道吗？我有一种感觉，每次我们试图帮你铺那个桌布时，你都会对我们大吼大叫。我觉得才没有。这就是为什么我们不帮你铺。我觉得才没有。你大概会挑剔我们是怎么做事的。这就是我，为什么没有人帮你铺桌布？因为你们是一群
slackers. Nope. I think because you, because you'll say just as you, you're about to shoot down a child. And so I'm just saying. Anyway, this might be why it's all on you. She's trying to set up for this party. Ryan and Kelly aren't helping. I mean, Kelly's looking at Ryan. Ryan's like, don't look at me. And I'm in the meantime, like, anyway, Toby walks in with Sasha, his daughter, and she very sweetly says, can I help? So sweet. So sweet. Angela's like, no, no, I'd have to explain everything to you. But no. And then Kelly, I look at Kelly and I'm like, no. And I love Paul's delivery of like, well, I didn't see it going that way. Yeah. Like, he's like, it's not what I was expecting. Not what I
懒虫。才不。我觉得是因为你，因为你会说，就在你，你正准备把一个孩子给轰走的时候。所以我只是说说而已。不管怎样，这也许就是为什么所有事都得你一个人扛。她正在为这个派对做准备。瑞恩和凯利根本不帮忙。我是说，凯利看着瑞恩。瑞恩的表情就像是，别看我。与此同时，不管怎样，托比带着他的女儿萨莎走了进来，她非常甜美地说，我能帮忙吗？太甜了。太甜了。安吉拉就像是，不，不用，我得跟你解释所有事情。还是算了。然后凯利，我看着凯利，然后我说，不用。而且我超喜欢保罗的表现，就是，嗯，我没想到事情会这样发展。对。就像，他觉得，这不是我预料的。不是我
was expecting. Yes. I love that scene. Kelly was so excited. She's like, I love babies. I can't wait to have babies. Ryan is really funny in this episode. BJ is great. He has some really funny moments. And he's just like, basically Kelly, just her idea of hooking up is just having babies with me as soon as possible. Well, his talking head, he's like, Kelly and I agreed we were just going to have fun. But what I'm realizing is that fun for Kelly means getting married and having babies as soon as possible with me. So that's her definition of having fun. And don't hook up with anyone like that on February 13th. That's right. I like your line in this scene, Angela. I get quoted this a lot. Yeah. When she asked
预料的。是的。我很喜欢那个场景。凯利当时超级兴奋。她说，我喜欢宝宝。我等不及要生宝宝了。瑞恩在这集里真的很好笑。BJ太棒了。他有一些非常搞笑的时刻。他基本上就是觉得，凯利对约会的想法就是尽快跟我生小孩。好吧，在他的单人采访里，他说，凯利和我原本说好只是随便玩玩的。但我现在意识到，凯利的“玩玩”意味着尽快跟我结婚并生小孩。这就是她对“玩玩”的定义。千万别在2月13日和这种人约会。没错了。安吉拉，我很喜欢你在这个场景里的台词。我经常被引用这句话。对。当她问
me if I would like to have kids and I say, well, maybe some small, well-behaved boys. Yeah. So weird. Small, well-behaved boys. Small. I don't want big, big boys. Apparently not. I don't want tiny, petite boys. All right. So next up, Michael is on the phone to corporate and Toby's daughter, Sasha walks in. Yeah. She then she leaves, but then she comes back later and starts playing with his toy train. They're so sweet together. So sweet. Michael is so tickled. He's having such a great time with her. I know. They do the train whistle. And he really, Steve, when we were filming that, Steve actually kept making the kids crack up. Do you remember that? I remember how hard it was for Hayley to keep a straight
我是否想要孩子时，我说，嗯，也许只要几个瘦小、乖巧的男孩。对。太诡异了。瘦小、乖巧的男孩。瘦小。我不要又高又大的大男孩。显然不要。我不要娇小的小男孩。好吧。接下来，迈克尔正在给总公司打电话，托比的女儿萨莎走了进来。对。然后她离开了，但后来她又回来了，开始玩他的玩具火车。他们在一起太有爱了。太有爱了。迈克尔觉得开心极了。他和她在一起度过了一段非常美好的时光。我知道。他们模仿火车的鸣笛声。而且真的，史蒂夫，我们在拍摄的时候，史蒂夫其实一直在逗得小孩子们哈哈大笑。你还记得吗？我记得海莉要保持扑克脸有多难，
face and Delaney too. Steve was cracking her up. It was really sweet. But we had a couple of fan questions about that. Katie Procedo said, I always love episodes where we get to see Michael interacting with kids because you can just tell that Steve Carell likes being around kids. He's a great dad. He is. And Beth White said, is Steve really this good with kids in real life? Yes. He is. He is. He is. The kids were so tickled by him. He's a sweetheart. And we should say you mentioned earlier, Angela, how families would sometimes come and visit. Steve was such a great ambassador for the show. He would always go into our green room and meet the families and take the kids on a little tour and show
德莱尼也是。史蒂夫一直在逗笑她。这真的很温馨。但我们收到了一些关于那的粉丝问题。凯蒂·普罗切多说，我总是很喜欢能看到迈克尔和孩子们互动的剧集，因为你能看出史蒂夫·卡瑞尔本人就很喜欢和孩子们在一起。他是个好爸爸。他确实是。贝丝·怀特说，史蒂夫在现实生活中对小孩子真的这么好吗？是的。他的确是。他真的是。小孩子们被他逗得开心极了。他是个大好人。我们应该说，安吉拉，你刚才提到过家属有时会来参观。史蒂夫一直是该剧非常棒的亲善大使。他总是会去我们的休息室见见家属，带孩子们参观一下，给他们看
them his office. Yes. Well, I think now Pam is going to try to get Abby to help her shred some old documents. Shut down. Yeah. Pam gets shut down. No. Abby's reading on the couch in reception. But then Jim says, hey, I've read that book. They have a little banter. They bond. Yeah. Abby agrees to help him with sales. Now, I want to say something here. Oh, okay. I feel a soapbox coming. It's tiny. It's a very, it's a small opinion. Okay. Observation. Okay. Jim knows that it's Pam's goal to be friend to kid. But rather than help her bond with Abby, he just kind of shows off and steals Abby away. I think this is hurt feelings Pam talking because I thought that was a little bit of like passive aggressive. I don't know
他的办公室。是的。好吧，我觉得现在帕姆要试着让艾比帮她碎一些旧文件。碰壁了。对。帕姆碰壁了。没有。艾比正坐在前台的沙发上看书。但接着吉姆说，嘿，我看过那本书。他们进行了一番闲聊。他们培养了感情。对。艾比同意帮他做销售。现在，我想在这里说点什么。哦，好吧。我感觉又要开始长篇大论了。这很小。这是一个非常小的观点。好吧。观察。好吧。吉姆知道帕姆的目标是跟小孩做朋友。但比起帮她和艾比建立感情，他反而在那儿出风头，把艾比给拉走了。我觉得这是受伤的帕姆在说话，因为我觉得那有点像是被动攻击。我不知道
what it is, but it was a little bit of like, come on, it's not that hard. I can do it. Like like Jim, watch me bond with a kid. So it's like a competition. Oh, yes. It felt a little bit weirdly competitive. Okay. Do you not see that? Well, I guess I do. I guess I also just thought Jim was being really nice. No, he knows Pam's goal. And I think if he were really being nice, at the end of that whole spiel, he would have said, and Pam, why don't you join us? Or he might have said, you know, who else loves books? Pam? Yes. Yes. This is what I'm saying. He doesn't help facilitate anything. He just comes in and shows off. Maybe it's not his job to help Pam. It is. It is his job to help her. Pam is not his
这是什么，但那有点像是，拜托，这没那么难。我能做到。就像，吉姆，看我跟一个小孩打成一片。所以这就像是一场竞争。哦，是的。感觉有点诡异的竞争意味。好吧。你没看出来吗？嗯，我猜我确实看出来了。我猜我同时也觉得吉姆只是表现得很友好。不，他知道帕姆的目标。而且我觉得如果他真的够友好的话，在整个长篇大论结束时，他会说，帕姆，你要不要加入我们？或者他可能会说，你知道还有谁也喜欢书吗？帕姆？对。是的。这就是我要说的。他没有促进任何事情的发生。他只是插进来然后出风头。也许帮帕姆不是他的工作。是的。帮她是他的工作。帕姆不是他的
responsibility. Pam is getting married. He's ticked off. See, that's what I'm saying. Oh, that's what I'm saying. That's what's underneath it. If, see, before they got in all these little fights and all the wedding date was set, I think Jim would have facilitated. Maybe. But now he's like boundary Jim. Now he's like, I have boundaries. I don't help you anymore because I'm not your fiance. Also, maybe I'm practicing self care, Pam. Wow. See what side you're on. Okay. Okay. Okay. Here we go. Well, let's talk about how Dwight is doing with the kids. Okay, let's. Abby is hanging out with Jim and Jim's doing that thing where, you know, she's shaking his hand. He's like, oh man, you're crushing me. Oh wait, I watched
责任。帕姆要结婚了。他气坏了。看，这就是我要说的。哦，这就是我要说的。这就是背后的潜台词。如果，看，在他们陷入这些小争吵并且定下婚礼日期之前，我觉得吉姆会促进这一切的。也许吧。但现在他就像是“划清界限的吉姆”。现在他就像是，我有界限。我不再帮你了，因为我不是你的未婚夫。还有，也许我在进行自我关照呢，帕姆。哇。看看你站在哪一边。好吧。好吧。好吧。我们开始吧。好吧，我们来聊聊德怀特跟孩子们相处得怎么样。好吧，我们聊聊。艾比和吉姆待在一起，吉姆正在做那种，你知道的，她在跟他握手。他说，哦天哪，你把我手都要捏碎了。哦等等，我跟伊莎贝尔一起看了
this with Isabel. Okay. And so when Dwight's like, you're not even, she's not that tough. I'll show you. She's like, what is wrong with Dwight, mom? He's so literal. He is. He is childlike himself. It's true. It's true. And then after that, Meredith's son comes over to Dwight's desk and starts touching all his bobbleheads. Hold up. Where's the Dwight bobblehead? Well, Melinda Magercouth would like to know that as well. Seven minutes, one second. Where is Angela's gift to Dwight? Thank you, Melinda. I am hoping Melinda that Dwight saw all those children there and feared for its safety. And with loving care, locked it in his drawer. He has one drawer that locks. It's on the left side of his desk. And I hope
这个。好吧。所以当德怀特说，你根本就不，她没那么厉害。我给你瞧瞧。她说，妈妈，德怀特怎么了？他怎么这么死板。他确实很死板。他自己就跟个小孩子似的。确实如此。确实如此。然后在那之后，梅丽莎的儿子走到德怀特的桌子旁，开始乱摸他所有的摇头娃娃。等一下。德怀特的摇头娃娃呢？琳达·麦格库思也很想知道这一点。7分1秒。安吉拉送给德怀特的礼物在哪里？谢谢你，琳达。我希望，琳达，德怀特看到那里有那么多小孩子，担心它的安全。所以怀着满腔爱意，把它锁在了他的抽屉里。他有一个会锁上的抽屉。就在他桌子的左侧。我希望
it's locked there for safety. You know what? Let's say that that's where it is. During this scene, Meredith's son refers to Meredith as Meredith. And Dwight is Mr. Poop. Yeah. He's being a jerk. He's being a jerk. And Jim and Abby laugh. Oh, they think it's so funny. They're like, now they're like totally in cahoots. I loved when Sasha goes up to Phyllis and says, are you Mother Goose? Yes. We were also tickled by that when we read it at the table read. I remember I laughed so hard at that observation. If anyone should ever be cast as Mother Goose, it is Phyllis. And Phyllis's reaction, though, is so brilliant. And so Isabelle and I were watching it together. So we went and we wanted to see what a picture
它被安全地锁在那里。你知道吗？我们就当它是放在那里的吧。在这个场景中，梅丽莎的儿子管梅丽莎叫梅丽莎。而德怀特是“便便先生”。对。他真是个混蛋。他就是个混蛋。然后吉姆和艾比笑了。哦，他们觉得太好笑了。他们就像是完全成了一伙的。我超喜欢萨莎走到菲莉丝面前说，你是鹅妈妈吗？对。我们在台本朗读会上读到这里时也被逗乐了。我记得我对那个观察结果笑得超大声。如果说谁最应该被选角演鹅妈妈，那绝对是菲莉丝。不过，菲莉丝的反应简直太绝了。所以伊莎贝尔和我当时正一起看。于是我们就想去找一张
of Mother Goose looked like. Does it look like Phyllis? Looks like Phyllis. 100%. 100%. They're showing me a drawing of Mother Goose. And it looks like Phyllis. And she's even like wearing purple. You know what I mean? Yeah. I know Phyllis was wearing purple in the scene, this whole episode. I wondered if they sort of looked at Phyllis. She was always in purple. She was in purple a lot. If you went to Phyllis's house and looked in her closet, it would just be purple outfits. And lots of like beaded jewelry. Yes. Always with some beaded necklaces. It's so true. And I just realized. What? You kind of took your daughter to work. Oh, because she watched the episode with me? Because she watched it
鹅妈妈的照片来看看。长得像菲莉丝吗？长得像菲莉丝。百分之百。百分之百。他们正在给我看一张鹅妈妈的画。长得就跟菲莉丝一模一样。而且她甚至还穿着紫色衣服。你知道我的意思吗？对。我知道菲莉丝在这个场景里一直穿着紫色，整集都是。我在想他们是不是参考了菲莉丝。她总是穿紫色。她经常穿紫色。如果你去菲莉丝家翻翻她的衣柜，里面肯定全都是紫色的衣服。还有很多串珠首饰。是的。总会戴着一些串珠项链。确实如此。我刚刚意识到。什么？你好像带你女儿上班了。哦，因为她跟我一起看了这集？因为她跟你一起
with you. Yes, I guess I did. You took your daughter to work for Take Your Daughter to Work Day. We're office ladies. Yeah. I did. That's kind of sweet. That's so funny. All right, seven minutes, 53 seconds. We're back in the kitchen and Melissa and Ryan are talking. And Melissa's like, so I thought it was really funny in sort of the way they wrote her eighth grade brain to try to impress Ryan is that she drinks coffee all day. Yeah. The ice, much, a lot of whatever it's all day. Yeah, she can't get enough of them. Yeah. Ryan, you're such a dork. You haven't been to Jitter's. Oh my God. Give me your phone number. He's like, uh. Yeah, speaking of Jitters at Steamtown Mall. So Steamtown Mall is a real place.
看了。是的，我想我是带了。你在带女儿上班日把女儿带去上班了。我们是Office Ladies。对。我是带了。这还挺温馨的。太搞笑了。好吧，7分53秒。我们回到了厨房，梅丽莎和瑞恩在聊天。梅丽莎说，所以我以为很好笑的是，他们写她八年级大脑试图给瑞恩留下深刻印象的方式竟然是她一整天都在喝咖啡。对。冰咖啡，超多，不管什么，反正就是一整天都在喝。对，她喝不够。对啊，瑞恩，你真是个书呆子。你没去过Jitters吗？哦天哪。把你的电话号码给我。他就说，呃。对，说到Steamtown购物中心的Jitters。Steamtown购物中心是个真实的地方。
Yeah, we've been there. It's in the center of the city of Scranton. Yeah. I could not find a Jitters today or in the past. I spent a good 40 minutes looking for it. Well, that's 40 minutes of your life. You're never getting back. I'm never getting back. But guys, if there is or ever was a Jitters, will you let me know? Because Jenna needs that 40 minutes back. I just need an answer. You need an answer. Yeah. Validate that 40 minutes. Well, during this whole conversation about Jitters in the Kitchen, Kelly. Kelly is vicious. Kelly is the type of gal that if you step on her like territory, like her man space in any way, she's going to burn you to the ground. And she does. She decimates Ryan. She goes and tattles immediately to Stanley. She points. She
是的，我们去过那里。它在斯克兰顿市中心。对。我今天或过去都没找到 Jitters 咖啡馆。我花了足足 40 分钟找它。好吧，那是你再也拿不回来的 40 分钟生命。我再也拿不回来了。但是大家，如果曾经或现在有 Jitters 这个地方，你们能告诉我吗？因为珍娜需要拿回那 40 分钟。我只是需要一个答案。你需要一个答案。对。证明那 40 分钟是有价值的。嗯，在关于“厨房里的 Jitters”的整个对话中，凯莉。凯莉太恶毒了。凯莉就是那种如果你侵犯了她的地盘，比如以任何方式侵犯了她的男人空间，她就会把你赶尽杀绝的人。她也确实这么做了。她把莱恩贬得一文不值。她立刻去向斯坦利打小报告。她指着
was like, I have something fishy going on over there. I don't know. They're talking a lot. I've been watching them all day. Yeah. And Stanley is pissed. Okay. This leads us to the scene that we got more male than any other scene in this episode. The scene when Stanley confronts Ryan in the break room. This was called out as many people's favorite fan question from Chris Johnson. How many takes did it take to get the Stanley Ryan scene? I tried to text Leslie. We need to get Leslie in here. We do. I tried to reach out to him. He's traveling right now. Okay. So I know from the bloopers, because there are great bloopers on YouTube of this, that he completely made BJ lose it. Oh yeah. It's season two bloopers at the three minute mark.
说，我那边有点不对劲。我不知道。他们聊了很多。我盯了他们一整天了。对。而斯坦利气炸了。好的。这把我们带到了本集中获得最多邮件的场景。就是斯坦利在茶水间质问莱恩的那个场景。克里斯·约翰逊（Chris Johnson）把它评为许多人最喜欢的粉丝提问。拍斯坦利和莱恩的那场戏拍了多少条？我试着给莱斯利发信息。我们需要把莱斯利请到这儿来。我们会的。我试着联系他。他现在正在旅行。好吧。所以我从NG花絮中知道——因为YouTube上有这个的精彩花絮——他把BJ彻底整崩溃了。哦，对。在第三分钟时，那是第二季的NG花絮。
I watched it as well. Okay. Stanley is letting Ryan have it. Leslie improvised a ton. That whole thing was like, Jesus isn't going to help you. None of them are going to help you. He was fantastic in that scene. And now we're going back to the conference room. And Dwight is playing the recorder for the kids. And he's got this on the table. He's got corn husk and plates and cups of ribbons and things. Yeah. There's going to be some kind of crafting project. Yeah. I had a fan question from Laura. Okay. Rain's recorder playing his top notch. Did he really play the recorder or was it added in later? No, he really played that. Yeah. He played the bassoon in high school. Yeah. He plays the recorder again in the bird funeral. Yes. When Pam sings along. So Rain is recorder
我也看了。好吧。斯坦利对莱恩大发雷霆。莱斯利即兴发挥了很多。整段都是诸如，“耶稣也帮不了你。他们谁也帮不了你。”他在那场戏里棒极了。现在我们要回到会议室。德怀特正在为孩子们吹竖笛。他的桌上有这个。他有玉米皮、盘子、缎带杯子之类的东西。对。要搞某种手工制作的项目。对。我有一个来自劳拉的粉丝提问。好吧。雷恩的竖笛吹得太棒了。他是真的在吹竖笛，还是后来配音加上去的？不，他是真的在吹。对。他高中时吹过巴松管。对。他在小鸟葬礼上又吹了竖笛。是的。帕姆跟着一起唱。所以雷恩的竖笛
proficient. He is a recorder player. Yeah. He is. Now he's also reading a book. Wait, wait, before we get to that, oh, hold up. This is big. This is one of my biggest cards of this episode. What is it? He might not be saying much. This is a big card for me. He finishes playing the song and he goes, that was green sleeves. That's an English ballad written about the beheading of Anne Boleyn. Okay. So, you know, I did a term paper on Anne Boleyn in college. I love Anne Boleyn. No, in high school. Oh, yes. In high school. Senior term paper. But I looked up green sleeves. Okay. This was fascinating to me. Sorry about to geek out on you guys a little bit. There is a persistent belief that green sleeves was composed by Henry VIII for his lover Anne Boleyn. Here's
很熟练。他是个竖笛手。对。他是。现在他还在看书。等等，等等，在我们讲到那个之前，哦，等等。这很重要。这是我关于这一集的最大卡片之一。是什么？他可能没说太多。这对我是张大卡片。他吹完歌，然后说，那是《绿袖子》。那是一首关于斩首安妮·博林的英国民谣。好吧。所以，你知道的，我在大学里写过关于安妮·博林的学期论文。我喜欢安妮·博林。不，是在高中。哦，是的。在高中。高中的毕业学期论文。但我查了《绿袖子》。好吧。这让我觉得太迷人了。抱歉，我要跟你们稍微极客一下。有一种根深蒂固的信念认为，《绿袖子》是亨利八世为他的情人安妮·博林创作的。这是
what really threw me for a loop. Ready? Yeah. There's this other interpretation of the lyrics. Ready? Yeah. Lady green sleeves was a promiscuous young woman, even perhaps a prostitute. Okay. At the time, the word green had sexual connotations, most notably in the phrase a green gown, a reference to the grass stains on a woman's dress from engaging in sexual intercourse in a field somewhere. Green is kind of hoarse. Green is kind of hoarse. This justifies that whole line for Angela Martin. I freaked out. I was in my, that's what she said. And I'm like, green is hoarse. I'm sure my neighbors are like, what is happening? Lady green was like a dirty color. Great bind, Angela. Thank you. That is some deep diving historian type work.
真正让我大吃一惊的地方。准备好了吗？对。对歌词还有另一种解读。准备好了吗？对。绿袖子女士是一个轻浮的年轻女子，甚至可能是个妓女。好吧。当时，“绿色”这个词带有性暗示，最显著的例子就是短语“一件绿色长袍”，指的是女性在某个地方的田野里进行性交时，裙子上沾上的草渍。绿色有点低级。绿色有点低级。这就为主播安娜·马丁的那句台词提供了正当理由。我吓坏了。我当时在想，这就是她说的。然后我想，绿色太低级了。我敢肯定我的邻居们在想，发生什么事了？绿夫人就像是个肮脏的颜色。干得漂亮，安娜。谢谢。这真是一些深入挖掘的历史学家的工作。
On the internet. To prove a reference line from the office. Well done. Thank you. I give you this. Thank you. I want to give you that. I take that. I take that. All right. So also in this scene, he is reading a book called Struwell Peter. We had a fan question from Tyler O'Donnell. Was the story that Dwight reads the kids a real folktale or was it something the writers made up? Gang, it's real. It's real. Loosely translated, it means shaggy Peter. It was a German. That sounds dirty. Shaggy. Don't wave your shaggy Peter at me. It sounds inappropriate. It does. Okay. So it's a story about shaggy Peter. I went out last night and this guy had such a shaggy Peter. Jenna, we're going to get the E. All right. So it is a German book
在互联网上。为了证明办公室里的一句引用台词。干得好。谢谢。我把这个交给你。谢谢。我想把那个交给你。我接受那个。我接受那个。好吧。所以也是在这个场景里，他在读一本叫《杂毛彼得》的书。我们有一个来自泰勒·奥唐纳的粉丝提问。德怀特读给孩子们听的故事是一个真正的民间故事，还是编剧们编造的？各位，它是真的。它是真的。意译过来，意思是蓬乱的彼得。它是一个德国的。听起来很色情。蓬乱的。别把你的蓬乱彼得在我面前晃来晃去。听起来很不合适。确实。好吧。所以这是一个关于蓬乱彼得的故事。我昨晚出门，这家伙有个好蓬乱的彼得。珍娜，我们要收到美国联邦通信委员会的警告了。好吧。所以这是一本德国的书
of cautionary tales for children. All right. Okay. Written by Heinrich Hoffman in 1845. Now, I found this fascinating. Heinrich Hoffman wanted to get a Christmas present for his three year old son. Okay. And he could not find a good children's book. I'm sorry, Heinrich. So he wrote his own. He wrote it himself. About shaggy Peter. Yes. He wrote Struwell Peter. Struwell Peter. And it was so sort of popular, I guess, among people that Heinrich knew that it was eventually published. Let's cut off their thumbs. Yeah, exactly. It's in the story. Here's a super crazy fact. What? In 1891, Mark Twain wrote a translation of this book that he called Slovenly Peter. Slovenly Peter. Yes. Which was published, but not until 1935, 25 years after
是给儿童的警告故事集。好啦。好吧。由海因里希·霍夫曼于1845年编写。现在，我觉得这很迷人。海因里希·霍夫曼想给三岁的儿子买一份圣诞礼物。好吧。他找不到一本好的儿童书。对不起，海因里希。所以他自己写了一本。他自己写的。关于蓬乱的彼得。是的。他写了《杂毛彼得》。杂毛彼得。而且它在海因里希认识的人中间非常受欢迎，我想，以至于它最终出版了。让我们割掉他们的拇指。对，没错。书里就是这么写的。这里有一个超级疯狂的事实。什么？在1891年，马克·吐温写了这本书的译本，他称之为《邋遢的彼得》。邋遢的彼得。是的。它出版了，但直到1935年才出版，也就是
Mark Twain died. And you and I are going to write our version called Shaggy Peter. There are 10 stories in this book. So in addition to the thumb-sucking story that Dwight reads the kids, which is true and in the book, there is also a story about a little girl who plays with matches, accidentally lights herself on fire and dies. Then there's the story of a boy who doesn't want to eat his soup for dinner. He holds out for five days and then starves to death. And dies. Do all the kids die or get maimed? No, no, not all of them. Some of them live through their rebellions but are forever like sort of maimed or sort of just, you know, not the same emotionally. Kind of. Yeah. Well, that's fun. Yeah. Oh, God. So that's the book. It's real. Well,
马克·吐温死后25年。你和我将要写我们的版本，叫《蓬乱的彼得》。这本书里有10个故事。所以除了德怀特读给孩子们听的吮吸手指的故事——这是真的，而且书里就有——还有一个故事讲的是一个小女孩玩火柴，不小心把自己点着了然后死了。然后还有一个故事讲的是一个男孩晚餐不想喝汤。他坚持了五天，然后饿死了。并且死了。所有的孩子都死了或者致残了吗？不，不，不是全部。有些人在他们的叛乱中活了下来，但永远像是某种程度上的残疾，或者只是，你知道的，在情感上不再一样了。差不多吧。对。好吧，那真有趣。对。哦，天哪。所以这就是这本书。它是真的。好吧，
we really get a window into Dwight and Angela's childhoods in this episode. Oh, yeah. I mean, Dwight grew up reading these stories with his grandmother. Yes. And then Angela is like, listen, my father was a strict disciplinarian. So you better whip these kids into shape. That's right. They are a perfect match. I say it over and over. They really are. They really are. At nine minutes, 47 seconds, we do pan to the table where Dwight has laid out supplies to make corn husk dolls. No one ever makes them, but the supplies are there. We had a fan question from Lauren Page, who actually made the corn husk dolls that Dwight plans to make with the kids. Was it Phil Shea? I would say Phil Shea. It was, Lauren. Yeah. Phil Shea was
我们在这一集里真正窥见了德怀特和安娜的童年。哦，是的。我是说，德怀特是在祖母的陪伴下读着这些故事长大的。是的。然后安娜就像是，听着，我父亲是一个严格的纪律严明的人。所以你最好把这些孩子管教好。没错。他们天生一对。我一遍又一遍地说。他们真的是。他们真的是。在9分47秒时，我们确实把镜头摇向了桌子，德怀特在那里摆好了制作玉米皮娃娃的材料。从来没有人做过，但材料都在那儿。我们有一个来自劳伦·佩奇的粉丝提问，到底是谁制作了德怀特计划和孩子们一起做的玉米皮娃娃？是菲尔·谢伊吗？我猜是菲尔·谢伊。是的，劳伦，就是他。菲尔·谢伊是
responsible for all of those items on the table. Phil Shea is a jack of many trades. Like he really had to do a lot. He does. Yeah. I just love it that now our questions come in with like specifics. Like, am I spotting a Phil Shea moment? Yes. Lauren, you're spotting a Phil Shea moment. I think we should take a little break. Okay. Because Michael is about to give the kids a tour of the office. And I think that deserves its own space. Right. It's really sweet. It's sweet. Let's take a break. Take a break. All right. We're back. We got some food. There's a bagel bar. Angela's eating an everything bagel. Well, there's much butter as I could put on it.
负责桌上所有这些物品的人。菲尔·谢伊是个多面手。他真的得做很多事。他确实做到了。对。我只是觉得很喜欢，现在我们的问题都带了具体细节。比如，我是不是发现了一个菲尔·谢伊的时刻？是的，劳伦，你发现了一个菲尔·谢伊的时刻。我想我们应该休息一下。好吧。因为迈克尔马上要带孩子们参观办公室了。我觉得这值得有它自己的空间。对。真的很温馨。很温馨。我们休息一下。休息一下。好吧。我们回来了。我们有点吃的。有个百吉饼吧。安娜正在吃一个“全料百吉饼”。嗯，上面抹了我能抹的尽可能多的黄油。
Don't judge me. What? Don't judge me. Okay. We won't judge you because we can't understand you. I love butter. Okay. Angela, before we get started, I want to take a moment because I feel like there's something I have to say to you. It's just like, do I need a glass of wine moment? Like, is it that big of a moment? Or am I okay with my bagel and butter? You're fine with your bagel and butter. Okay. I feel like it's something that I need to say. I'm saying it reluctantly, yet with enthusiasm. Is it about my hair today? Nope. Okay. It's not about your hair. All right. I'm going to say it. I'm going to say it. But once I say it, it's been said. I love Game of Thrones. Yes. Yes. I told you you would. I told you you would. Where are you?
别评判我。什么？别评判我。好吧。我们不会评判你，因为我们无法理解你。我喜欢黄油。好吧，安娜，在我们开始之前，我想花点时间，因为我觉得有些话我不得不对你说。这就像是那种“我需要一杯酒”的时刻吗？有那么夸张吗？还是说我对我的百吉饼和黄油挺满意的？你对你的百吉饼和黄油挺满意的。好吧。我觉得这是我有话要说。我是不情愿却又带着热情说出来的。是关于我今天的头发吗？不。好吧。不是关于你的头发。好吧。我要说了。我要说了。但一旦我说了，它就已经说出口了。我喜欢《权力的游戏》。耶。耶。我告诉过你会的。我告诉过你会的。你看到哪了？
What's happened? End of season one. Spoilers. End of season one. Oh, Khaleesi out of the fire. I mean, Angela with her dragons. When Khaleesi rises out of the fire. I am Khaleesi. First of my name, mother of dragons. She's got three baby dragons on her. Yeah. I was like, I was, I was like, oh my God, I am Khaleesi with three baby dragons. And my dragons are just going to get bigger. I was like, I'm a woman coming into her own. I'm with you Khaleesi. Everyone out there who was really, I got a lot of mail and support from people out there who were like, Jenna, you do not need to watch Game of Thrones. You do not need to, we, like we were in it together. I feel like I'm letting some folks down. You told me it was a soap opera, a fantasy soap opera.
发生什么了？第一季结束。剧透。第一季结束。哦，龙妈浴火重生。我是说安娜带着她的巨龙。当龙妈从烈火中站起来。我是龙妈。我的名字叫卡妮莉亚，龙之母。她身上有三条小龙。耶。我当时想，我当时想，哦天哪，我就是带着三条小龙的龙妈。而且我的龙会越长越大。我想，我是一个正在蜕变成长、独当一面的女性。我支持你，龙妈。外面所有那些——我收到了很多邮件和支持，来自那些说“珍娜，你不需要看《权力的游戏》，你不需要看”的人——就像我们是一起经历的。我觉得我让一些人失望了。你告诉过我这是一部肥皂剧，一部奇幻肥皂剧。
Well, it is a fantasy soap opera. A little bit. But it's more than that. Well, you know what? I'm just going to say that I was wrong about it. But I do, I'm going to stand by the Star Wars. Okay. Okay. You know what? I'll take it. I'll take it. I got one. I got one. Yeah. I got GOT with you. Yeah. I'm good. I'm in it. I'm in it to win it on GOT. Okay. Michael takes the kids over to Creed. Okay. And he says, this is Creed. He's in charge of something. Right. And Creed says, that is correct. Yeah. Cause Creed doesn't know what he's in charge of. Creed doesn't know either. No one knows. And then, and then of course, Creed is like the showstopper crowd pleaser when he's like, you want to see a foot with four toes? Yeah. And they're so excited and Creed is giddy.
嗯，它确实是一部奇幻肥皂剧。有点吧。但它不止于此。好吧，你知道吗？我只想说我之前看走眼了。但我还是要坚持《星球大战》。好吧。好吧。你知道吗？我接受。我接受。我中了一个。我中了一个。耶。我和你一起看《权力的游戏》了。耶。我很好。我在里面了。我势在必得，要看《权力的游戏》。好吧。迈克尔把孩子们带到克里德那里。好吧。他说，这是克里德。他负责某种东西。对。然后克里德说，完全正确。对。因为克里德根本不知道自己负责什么。克里德也不知道。没人知道。然后，然后当然，当克里德说“你想看看长着四个脚趾的脚吗？”时，他成了全场的焦点和开心果。对。
Creed can't wait to show him. Finally, someone wants to see his four toes. I know. But he says, don't worry. Like the hair covers up most of it. I know. What is he, his Hobbit feet? I guess so. Hobbit, Jenna, Lord of the Rings. I'm sorry. I'm not going to go there. I know. I'm not going to, that I will, I mean, I might watch a Star Wars one day, but you are not getting me into the Lord of the Rings. Right. That is where I draw the line. Okay, fine. All right. So we go into the conference room and all the kids are in there and they're eating candy. And this is when Michael tells them that he used to be the star. I know. Calls himself the star of a TV show called Fundle Bundle. Here's my question for you. Cause as I watched this, I kept thinking about this.
他们太兴奋了，克里德高兴极了。克里德等不及要展示了。终于有人想看他的四个脚趾了。我知道。但他说，别担心。就像头发遮住了大部分一样。我知道。他是什么，他的霍比特人脚？我想是的。霍比特人，珍娜，指环王。对不起。我不想扯到那儿去。我知道。我不会去——我是说，我有一天可能会看《星球大战》，但你绝对别想把我拉进《指环王》的坑里。好吧，那是我划清界限的地方。好吧，行吧。好吧，我们走进会议室，所有的孩子都在里面，他们在吃糖。这就是迈克尔告诉他们他曾经是个明星的时候。我知道。称自己为一档叫《Fundle Bundle》的电视节目的明星。我有问题要问你。因为当我看着这个时，我一直在想这个。
Is just Michael's memory of this just through rose colored glasses. He doesn't really remember what it was like. He's recreated sort of, he's rewritten history, if you will. Right? Yeah. Yeah. That he was the star and it was a great thing. Yes. I mean, I think that's pretty common. I'm thinking of the time, for example, that I got to be on the radio reading a poem about the St. Louis Cardinals during the World Series. How old were you? Oh, I was probably last year. No, I was like 10. I was 10. Yeah. Cause it was the 84 World Series, I believe. So I was 10. Okay. And my memory of it is that I was a radio star. But I'm sure if I heard the audio, it's me, like roses are red, violets are blue, I love the Cardinals and so do you. Right? Like I was probably
迈克尔对这件事的记忆是不是只通过有色眼镜？他根本不记得当时是什么样了。他重现了某种——如果你愿意的话，他重写了历史。对吧？对。对。他是明星，那是一件了不起的事。是的。我是说，我觉得这挺常见的。我想起有一次，例如，我在世界大赛期间在广播里朗读了一首关于圣路易斯红雀队的诗。你多大？哦，我大概去年吧。不，我大概10岁。我10岁。对。因为那是84年的世界大赛，我相信。所以我10岁。好吧。我的记忆是，我是一个广播明星。但我敢肯定，如果我听到录音，那一定是我在念，比如“玫瑰是红色的，紫罗兰是蓝色的，我爱红雀队，你也一样”。对吧？就像我可能
not the poetry reader you are now. And who knows what this poem really was. But in my mind, it was such a fabulous poem. It got live on the radio and we all listened. You know? So I think that's what's happened in Michael's brain. He has this childlike nostalgia of what that was. And Fundal Bundle, if it was anything like the Land of Hatchimalatchee, was a big deal in Scranton. Yeah. And so, and Michael was on it. This is a little bit of a claim to fame. Right. So he decides, we're going to watch it. He tells Ryan, go get the tape. Go get the tape from my mom's house. And then he goes into this very elaborate explanation. Go to Dixon City, which I looked up. It's about a 14 minute drive. Go to Dixon City. Mom might be by the pool. She might be at the pool. At the pool.
不是你现在这样的诗歌朗诵者。谁知道这首诗到底是什么呢。但在我的脑海里，它是一首多么美妙的诗啊。它在广播里现场直播了，我们都听了。你知道吗？所以我认为这就是迈克尔脑子里发生的事情。他对那个经历有着孩子般的怀旧之情。而《Fundle Bundle》，如果它有一点点像《哈查马拉奇乐园》的话，在斯克兰顿可是一件大事。对。所以，迈克尔当时在上面。这算是一点小小的名气。对。所以他决定，我们要看它。他告诉莱恩，去拿磁带。去我妈妈家拿磁带。然后他开始了一段非常详尽的解释。去迪克森城，我查过了。开车大约14分钟。去迪克森城。妈妈可能在泳池边。她可能在泳池。在泳池。
And so you're going to have to go through the window. Boost yourself up and go to the basement. Can we play this clip? It's at 12 minutes. I just love Steve delivers it very, very quickly. He just rattles it off as if everything he's saying is totally normal. And also, this is something he's done countless times. Yeah. It's so easy to do. This is how you get in my mind. She's going to be at the pool. Yeah. So you just, you put your, the window will be open though. Yeah. Here it is. I would like you to go to my mother's house in Dixon City. And if she is at the pool, the back kitchen window should be unlocked. I want you to boost yourself up. I want you to go down to the basement. In the basement is a tape labeled Fundal Bundle. I want you to grab it. I
所以你得从窗户爬进去。把自己托上去，去地下室。我们能放这段剪辑吗？在12分钟处。我只是喜欢史蒂夫说这段台词时非常非常快。他就像连珠炮似的一口气说完，就好像他说的所有事情都完全正常一样。而且，这是他做过无数次的事情。对。这太容易做到了。这就是你进入我脑子里的方式。她会在泳池。对。所以你只要，你把你的——不过窗户会开着的。对。在这儿。我希望你去我妈妈在迪克森城的房子。如果她在泳池，后厨房的窗户应该是开着的。我希望你把自己托上去。我希望你下到地下室。在地下室里有一卷贴着标签叫《Fundle Bundle》的磁带。我希望你把它拿来。我
want you to get my guitar. Right. Okay. I want you to get a tambourine. Do you know how to play the tambourine? Um, I'm already getting the pizzas from Brunetti. So you know, I can go with him. Oh, no, I will go. Okay. I love that. I love that. Oh, get my guitar, which is in his mother's basement. Yeah. And then can you play the tambourine? It's, it's, it's all about to happen. It's all about to happen. So at 12 minutes, 17 seconds, Ryan says he can't go because I'm already getting pizza from Brunetti's. Brunetti's is a real pizza place in Scranton. No jitters, but there is a Brunetti's. There is a Brunetti's, but guys, guess what? What? I went to the Facebook page for Brunetti's. Yeah. Their pizza is a rectangle. What? Rectangle pizza. Brunetti's scandalous.
希望你拿到我的吉他。对。好吧。我希望你拿一个铃鼓。你知道怎么弹铃鼓吗？嗯，我已经从布鲁内蒂那里拿披萨了。所以你知道的，我可以和他一起去。哦，不，我去。好吧。我喜欢那样。我喜欢那样。哦，把我的吉他拿来，它在他妈妈的地下室里。对。然后你能弹铃鼓吗？这，这，一切都要发生了。一切都要发生了。所以在12分17秒，莱恩说他不能去，因为我已经从布鲁内蒂那儿拿披萨了。布鲁内蒂是斯克兰顿的一家真正的披萨店。没有 Jitters，但确实有布鲁内蒂。确实有布鲁内蒂，但是各位，猜怎么着？什么？我去了布鲁内蒂的Facebook主页。对。他们的披萨是长方形的。什么？长方形的披萨。布鲁内蒂，太离谱了。
Not circular pizza. Like Barone's here. Barone's in Los Angeles. Steve's favorite pizza. Where we would get pizza sometimes on set. For the cast and crew. Square. Rectangle. Oh, rectangle. Yeah. It's made on like a cookie sheet. Well, in our episode, we have circular pizzas. To be fair, I did see they tend to sometimes serve circular ones. Well, you heard it here, you guys. You heard it here. Sorry for the circular pizza. When it wasn't Brunetti's rectangle pizza. All right, guys. Everybody is in the conference room now at 12 minutes 29 seconds. They're eating the circular pizza that should be a rectangle fan catch from Mrs. Cray. What? Mrs. Cray? What is the funny dance move that John Krasinski is doing in the background? I don't know. They're just
不是圆形的披萨。就像这里的巴龙披萨一样。洛杉矶的巴龙披萨。史蒂夫最喜欢的披萨。我们在片场有时会去那儿买披萨。给演员和剧组。正方形的。长方形的。哦，长方形的。对。它就像在烤盘上做的一样。好吧，在我们的那一集里，我们有圆形的披萨。公平地说，我确实看到他们有时倾向于供应圆形的。好吧，你们在这里听到了，各位。你们在这里听到了。抱歉给你们圆形的披萨。当它不是布鲁内蒂的长方形披萨时。好吧，各位。每个人现在都在会议室里，12分29秒。他们在吃本该是长方形的圆形披萨。来自克雷夫人的粉丝捕捉。什么？克雷夫人？约翰·卡拉辛斯基在背景里跳的那个搞笑舞蹈动作是什么？我不知道。他们只是
goofing around with the kids. It's just John being John. Yeah, he's just playing. That's John. Yeah. If you want to know what John is like, check out 12 minutes 29 seconds. Yeah, he's just having fun. He is. Are we ready to play this tape from Fundal Bundle? 12 minutes 51 seconds. The Fundal Bundle tape has arrived. We had a lot of fan questions about the Fundal Bundle video and how it was made. So I reached out to Kent Sabornak, our line producer. So he told me that our set designers built the set and that our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, found all of these vintage 1960s outfits for the kids. She was great at that. So good. And probably so excited because all we wore were gray turtlenecks and like beige tops. And so she was probably so thrilled to have a project.
在和孩子们胡闹。那只是约翰在做约翰。对，他只是在玩。那是约翰。对。如果你想知道约翰是什么样的，去看看12分29秒。对，他只是在玩得开心。他是。我们准备好播放这卷《Fundle Bundle》的磁带了吗？12分51秒。《Fundle Bundle》的磁带到了。我们收到了很多关于《Fundle Bundle》视频及其制作过程的粉丝提问。所以我联系了我们的制片主任肯·萨博纳克（Kent Sabornak）。他告诉我，我们的布景设计师搭建了布景，我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特（Carrie Bennett）为孩子们找到了所有这些1960年代的复古服装。她在这方面很在行。太棒了。而且可能超级兴奋，因为我们穿的全部都是灰色高领毛衣和米色上衣。所以她可能非常高兴能接手这样一个项目。
Here's an interesting bit of trivia about Carrie Bennett. Yeah. So before our show, Carrie worked on scrubs and she designed some kind of like, I guess, quote unquote designer scrubs. Well, she could sew. And so she designed her own line of scrubs that were less boxy, that were more flattering and fitted for both men and women. Right. Different colors and patterns. They were so popular that she actually started a line of scrubs. Yeah. Yeah. Go Carrie. So there you go. So when they shot this footage, they used a cheap video camera instead of one of our regular cameras. And then in post production, he told me they threw in some additional artifacts. I guess artifacts is a term for lessening the quality of the film image. And so that's how it got that
这里有一个关于凯莉·贝内特的有趣冷知识。是的。所以在我们的节目之前，凯莉曾在《实习医生风云》工作过，她设计了一种类似于——我猜是所谓的“设计师款”手术服。嗯，她会缝纫。所以她设计了自己的手术服系列，不那么方正，对男女来说都更修身、更好看。不同的颜色和图案。它们太受欢迎了，以至于她真的创立了一个手术服品牌。对。是的，加油，凯莉。所以你看。所以当他们拍摄这段素材时，他们用了一台廉价的摄像机，而不是我们常用的摄像机。然后在他告诉我后期的制作中，他们加入了一些额外的噪点。我猜噪点是用来降低电影图像质量的一个术语。这就是它是如何获得那种
degraded, grainy look. Yes. Yeah. We had another fan question from Karen Fryer. She said, who was the voice of Edward R. Meow, the puppet that all the kids are talking to in Fundal Bundle? The voice is Kevin Carlson. He is a puppeteer and voice actor, but here's something very sweet. What? I did not know this. Kent Zabornak, our line producer, used to be a puppeteer. Stop it. Yeah. He worked with Jim Henson. Kent? Kent Zabornak worked with Jim Henson and Sid and Mary Croft and he wanted to be Edward R. Meow. And they didn't let him? No. He couldn't do it in the end. He didn't have the time. He couldn't leave his job of line producing to be Edward R. Meow. So he asked his friend, another professional puppeteer, Kevin Carlson, if he would do it.
褪色的、有颗粒感的外观的。是的。是的。我们收到了来自凯伦·弗赖尔的另一个粉丝提问。她说，在《Fundle Bundle》中，所有孩子们都在交谈的那个木偶爱德华·R·米奥（Edward R. Meow）的声音是谁配的？声音是凯文·卡尔森（Kevin Carlson）。他是一个木偶师和配音演员，但这里有个非常温馨的事情。什么？我不知道这个。我们的制片主任肯·萨博纳克曾经是个木偶师。别逗了。真的。他跟吉姆·汉森合作过。肯？肯·萨博纳克跟吉姆·汉森以及西德和玛丽·克罗夫特合作过，他本想成为爱德华·R·米奥。他们没让他演？没有。他最后没能做到。他没有时间。他不能为了当爱德华·R·米奥而放下制片主任的工作。所以他问他的朋友，另一个专业木偶师凯文·卡尔森，他愿不愿意演。
This is that classic thing that I love, where you look at someone, you think you know them. You're like, I know you. You're very efficient. Kent's kind of like this high strung, but like nice and kind, but he's getting stuff done. He's got Excel spreadsheets. Yeah. And I'm like, Kent, I know who you are. And then you're a freaking puppeteer. Puppeteer. What? Yeah, I did not know. That blew me away when he told me that. I love that. Yeah. I love it. But here's something. What? The little blonde kid that gets interviewed by Edward R. Meow. The first kid? The first kid. Yeah. That's Kent Zabornak's son. Oh. Alec. That's so cute. He had to audition for the role and he got it. He got it. Yeah. He had to audition. Isn't that cute? That is so cute. Should we talk about
这就是那种我最喜欢的经典情况，你看着某个人，你以为你了解他们。你会想，我认识你。你非常高效。肯有点那种神经质，但是人很好很善良，而且他能把事情搞定。他有Excel电子表格。对。然后我想，肯，我知道你是谁。结果你是个该死的木偶师。木偶师。什么？是的，我不知道。当他告诉我的时候，这把我震惊到了。我喜欢这样。是的。我喜欢。但这里有个事。什么？接受爱德华·R·米奥采访的那个小金发男孩。第一个孩子？第一个孩子。对。那是肯·萨博纳克的儿子。哦。亚历克。太可爱了。他不得不为这个角色试镜，然后他得到了。他得到了。是的。他不得不试镜。这不是很可爱吗？太可爱了。我们应该谈谈
Chet Montgomery? We should. Chet, he's like a local celebrity. Yeah. So my hometown is pretty small, you know, in North Texas. And the evening news there is Good Evening, Texoma. Because we're right by the Texas-Oklahoma border. Okay. And the folks that do the news there, the local anchors, I have been in Wichita Falls with like my grandmother or mom or like at the mall or going to Lubies. They love Lubies. What's Lubies? Lubies is like. Do they sell earrings? No. It's like, it's my grandparents love to go there for lunch. You get a tray. Oh, it's an eating eatery. Yeah. You eat there. You get a tray and you go all the way down. It's like a buffet. Like a cafeteria style buffet thing. Yes. I'd love that place. Oh, yeah. Like a soup plantation. Kind of. Yeah.
切特·蒙哥马利（Chet Montgomery）吗？我们应该谈谈。切特，他就像个地方名人。对。所以我的家乡非常小，你知道，在德克萨斯州北部。那里的晚间新闻叫《晚安，特克索马》（Good Evening, Texoma）。因为我们就在德克萨斯州和俄克拉荷马州边界旁边。好吧。在那儿做新闻的人，当地的主播，我以前在威奇托福尔斯和我祖母或妈妈一起——比如在商场里，或者去露比餐厅。他们喜欢露比餐厅。露比餐厅是什么？露比餐厅就像是。他们卖耳环吗？不。就像是——我祖父母很喜欢去那里吃午饭。你拿一个托盘。哦，是一家餐馆。对。你在那儿吃饭。你拿一个托盘，然后一直往前走。就像自助餐一样。就像自助餐厅风格的自助餐那样。是的，我喜欢那个地方。哦，是的。就像汤园餐厅。有点像。是的。
Lubies. It was called Lubies. It's in the mall. But I remember going there with my grandparents and we saw the local news guy and they were like, there he is. Oh my God. That's the, he does the evening news. Oh my God. We're so excited. This kid who's being interviewed, he's Chet Montgomery. We find out he's the weather guy. Yeah. Right. He's played by Dimoni Roberts. Here is a crazy thing about Dimoni Roberts. What? Remember earlier in the talking head when Michael says, I'm Eddie Murphy and raw, but they're going to make me be Eddie Murphy and daddy daycare. Is Dimoni and daddy daycare? Yes. Stop it. Yes. That's amazing. Dimoni Roberts is also in daddy daycare. Fan question from Grace Marvel, 5005 and Chris Wolpert, who played Michael as a kid.
露比餐厅。它在商场里。但我记得我和祖父母去那里时，我们看到了当地的新闻主持人，他们当时就说，看呐。天哪。那是——他播晚安新闻。天哪。我们太激动了。这个正在接受采访的孩子，他是切特·蒙哥马利。我们发现他是天气预报员。对。没错。他由德莫尼·罗伯茨（Dimoni Roberts）扮演。关于德莫尼·罗伯茨，有一件疯狂的事。什么？还记得前面在谈话镜头里迈克尔说，我是粗俗的埃迪·墨菲，但他们要让我成为《奶爸别动队》里的埃迪·墨菲吗？德莫尼演了《奶爸别动队》？对。别逗了。是的。太神奇了。德莫尼·罗伯茨也出演了《奶爸别动队》。来自格蕾丝·漫威5005和克里斯·沃尔珀特的粉丝提问，谁演了小时候的迈克尔？
This was an actor named Jake Callender. Jake Callender. Jake Callender. He sounds like Chet Montgomery. He does. Jake Callender with evening news and Texoma. So when young Michael is interviewed, didn't you think young Michael looked like young Sheldon a little bit? Oh yeah. I can give you that. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Looks a little bit. Little bit. Okay. So he's interviewed. He's interviewed and he's asked what he wants to be when he grows up. We should also remind you guys, he's in a full suit and tie. Yeah. He's a little kid. Yeah. And he says, I want to be married and have 100 kids so I can have 100 friends and no one can say no to being my friend. Is this when you cried? This is when I had to turn off the episode. It hit me so hard. I don't know why this idea of
这是一个名叫杰克·卡伦德（Jake Callender）的演员。杰克·卡伦德。杰克·卡伦德。他听起来像切特·蒙哥马利。他确实像。特克索马晚间新闻的杰克·卡伦德。所以当年轻的迈克尔接受采访时，你不觉得年轻的迈克尔有点像小谢尔顿吗？哦，是的。我承认这一点。对吧？对。对。有点像。有点像。好吧。所以他接受了采访。他接受了采访，被问到长大后想做什么。我们还应该提醒你们，他穿着全套西装打着领带。对。他是个小孩子。对。他说，我想结婚，生100个孩子，这样我就可以有100个朋友，没有人可以说不当我的朋友。这就是你哭的时候吗？这就是我不得不关掉这一集的时候。它深深地触动了我。我不知道为什么这种想法
just this little kid longing for friends and longing for acceptance, but we're getting a real window into his life. Listen, it was just, it was almost too much for me. It was almost too much for me, the sentence about Michael's past. It was just, and I think because then you go to Steve's reaction and Steve's acting is so good in that moment. It just, it just like, I don't know. I mean, I remember at the time when we shot that, that after the little Michael says that, it cuts to a shot of the puppet and the puppet can't speak, then we lost it. The puppet is like a gape, right? His mouth is open. Do you know that the puppet, they linger on the puppet with its mouth open and silence? Like, what the heck? Right? Yeah. They linger on that puppet
这个小男孩只是渴望朋友和接纳，但我们真正窥见了他人生的冰山一角。听着，这只是——对我来说几乎太多了。对我来说几乎太多了，关于迈克尔过去的这句话。它只是——而且我想因为接着你就看到了史蒂夫的反应，史蒂夫在那一刻的演技太棒了。它只是——我不知道。我是说，我记得当年我们拍那场戏时，小迈克尔说出那句话后，镜头切到了木偶身上，木偶说不出话来，然后我们崩溃了。木偶目瞪口呆，对吧？他的嘴是张开的。你知道木偶吗，他们在一个张着嘴保持沉默的木偶身上停留了很久？就像，到底怎么回事？对吧？对。他们在那个木偶身上
for six seconds of silence. I mean, seeing a puppet with its mouth a gape being like, what the earth just is going on? It is funny. It is funny. And when we were shooting this? Six seconds. We were dying. We were dying at the shot of the puppet. And so when I was getting ready, I think to sit down and watch the scene, all I could remember was how we were crying, laughing at this reaction shot of the puppet. But then I saw, I just saw this whole other side of how not funny that was. Well, we were looking at the puppet. We weren't looking at Steve at that moment. Yeah. So we missed, we missed that moment for Michael. We needed to watch it as an episode. Yes. As an audience. Yeah. Yeah. I just was, anyway. Well, the kids start peppering Michael
停留了六秒钟的沉默。我是说，看到一个目瞪口呆的木偶，仿佛在说“这到底是什么鬼情况？”这很搞笑。这确实搞笑。而我们在拍这场戏的时候？六秒钟。我们笑得要死。我们看着木偶的反应镜头笑得前仰后合。所以当我准备好，我想坐下来看这个场景时，我能记住的全部就是我们是如何因为木偶这个反应镜头而笑得哭出来的。但后来我看到了，我只是看到了那有多不搞笑的另一面。好吧，我们在看木偶。我们那一刻没在看史蒂夫。对。所以我们错过了，错过了迈克尔的那一刻。我们需要把它当作一集剧来观看。是的。作为观众。是的。是的。我只是——不管怎样。好吧，孩子们开始用问题狂轰滥炸迈克尔，
with questions, right? Yeah. They're saying, well, did you get married? Do you have kids? Do you have a girlfriend? And then the little girl says, I guess you didn't get to be what you wanted to be. And it is soul crushing. And I was watching this with Isabel, who's 11. And she turned to me and she goes, Mom, were there just times when you were doing this show that you were like, I am so uncomfortable. She was like, this is really uncomfortable. I mean, she thought it was funny, you know, but she was like, that is awkward. And I was like, yeah, oh yeah, there are a lot of cringy moments on this show, which make it all work in balance. But just the fact that she picked up on that at her age of like, what an awkward moment this was.
对吧？对。他们在说，嗯，你结婚了吗？你有孩子吗？你有女朋友吗？然后那个小女孩说，我猜你没能成为你想成为的人。这太让人心碎了。我当时正和11岁的伊莎贝尔一起看。她转过身对我说，妈妈，你在拍这个节目的时候，有没有哪个时刻让你觉得“天哪，我太尴尬了”？她就像是，这真的很尴尬。我是说，她觉得这挺好笑的，你知道，但她觉得，那太难堪了。我就想，是的，哦是的，这个节目有很多让人脚趾抠地的时刻，这让所有这些在平衡中起作用。但仅仅是她在她那个年龄就体会到了这是一个多么尴尬的时刻。
Oh man. Well, Michael is so gutted. He just, he locks himself in his office. Yeah. He won't come out. And the reaction shots of all of us are great. We're all really sad for him. Sad. A little embarrassed. Yeah. All of it. So Pam's talking to Jim. We got a lot of mail about this little scene. Pam's talking to Jim. She's saying Michael won't come out of his office. He won't answer his phone over her shoulder. Roy is wrestling with Meredith's son. He's so happy. Roy, Roy and the jerk kid are having the best time. We had a lot of questions about what this scene was supposed to mean because Pam seems a little bit embarrassed or ashamed that Roy and this kid are getting along. They're like, what did this mean? Well, I think, I don't know. What was your
天哪。好吧，迈克尔彻底崩溃了。他把自己锁在办公室里。对。他就是不肯出来。我们所有人的反应镜头都很棒。我们都为他感到难过。难过。有点尴尬。对。全都有。所以帕姆在跟吉姆说话。我们收到了很多关于这个小场景的邮件。帕姆在跟吉姆说话。她说迈克尔不肯出办公室。他不接电话。在她的肩膀后面，罗伊正在和梅雷迪思的儿子摔跤。他太开心了。罗伊，罗伊和那个混蛋小孩玩得正开心。我们收到了很多关于这个场景到底意味着什么的问题，因为帕姆看起来有点尴尬或羞愧，因为罗伊和这小孩相处得这么融洽。他们说，这到底是什么意思？嗯，我觉得，我不知道。你的
interpretation? Here was my take on it. Okay. Because you have Roy, this big guy, right? And he's kind of fratty. He's kind of like a frat guy. And he is with the kid that's the asshole. Right. And they're having the time of their lives. They're in there. There's other people around them. They're not even caring about other people's personal space. They're wrestling in this room. And Roy's like, got him in a headlock and he's like, I love this kid. And I think Pam had a flash of what her life would be like with Roy, with children, what their kids would be like. Yeah. She was going to have a kid that's like, mom, pull my finger, fart, dad laugh. Yeah. And Pam was like, oh, God, well, no, I'm going to be outnumbered in my own house by like the Roy kids.
理解是什么？我的看法是这样的。好吧。因为你有罗伊这个大个子，对吧？他有点像那种兄弟会男生。他有点像兄弟会的那种家伙。他和那个混蛋小孩在一起。他们正在度过他们生命中最美好的时光。他们就在那里。他们周围还有其他人。他们甚至不在乎别人的个人空间。他们在这个房间里摔跤。罗伊就像是——把他锁喉了，还说，我太喜欢这小孩了。我想帕姆脑海里闪现出了如果她和罗伊有了孩子，她的生活会是什么样，他们的孩子会是什么样。对。她会生一个像这样的孩子，会说“妈妈，拉我的手指，放屁”，爸爸会大笑。对。然后帕姆就想，哦，天哪，好吧，不，我在自己家里要被罗伊家的这群人给包围了。
Yeah. I think it's definitely there to show a contrast to the way Jim bonds with a kid over books and reading, as opposed to just rough housing. Yeah. But I have to say, when I saw that, I thought, yes, that's what this kid needs. Actually, he needs a father figure in his life. He needs someone to wrestle with him because that is an important part of parenting. I didn't think that that was so bad of a thing. No, I think it's perfect for Roy. The problem is, that's not what Pam wants in a dad. Pam wants more of a Jim dad that is going to do a silly dance and talk about books and probably wrestle a little bit too. But I think Roy is just a little brutish. It's absolutely what Meredith's son needs. I mean, he needs a big guy to like grab
是的，我觉得这绝对是为了展现与吉姆通过书籍和阅读与孩子建立联系的方式形成鲜明对比，而不是仅仅进行粗暴的打闹。对。但我不得不说，当我看到那一幕时，我想，是的，这正是这个孩子需要的。实际上，他生活中需要一个父亲形象。他需要有人跟他摔跤，因为那是为人父母的重要组成部分。我不觉得那是一件多么糟糕的事。不，我觉得这非常适合罗伊。问题是，这并不是帕姆想要的爸爸。帕姆更想要那种会跳傻里傻气的舞、谈论书本、可能也会稍微摔跤一下的吉姆式爸爸。但我认为罗伊只是有点粗鲁。这绝对是梅雷迪思的儿子所需要的。我是说，他需要一个大块头来抓住
him and be like, hey, pay attention. But I just think it's just that moment that shows that Jim and Pam are just, you meet people, we all like dated people, and there's some people you know instinctively that you're going to parent the same with. Yeah. And I think Pam and Jim are going to parent the same. Yes. Yeah. I think that's good. That's good. That's good analysis. I like that. Well, next up, we go to the copier with Dwight and we're going to see how Dwight might parent Jake. Well, again, Dwight and Angela, Angela has told him he needs to be tougher with the kids. Basically, that's her subtext because that's what she would expect, right? That's what she had growing up and she expects him to be that way. Yeah. So she's egging him
他并对他说，嘿，注意点。但我只是觉得那一刻表明，吉姆和帕姆只是——你遇到过一些人，我们都和一些人约会过，有些人你凭直觉就知道你们的育儿方式会是一样的。是的。而且我认为帕姆和吉姆会用同样的方式抚养孩子。是的。是的。我觉得这很好。这很好。这分析得很好。我喜欢这个。好吧，接下来，我们和德怀特一起走到复印机旁，我们要看看德怀特会如何抚养杰克。嗯，还是那句话，德怀特和安娜，安娜告诉他，他对孩子们需要更严厉一点。基本上，这就是她的潜台词，因为那是她所期望的，对吧？那是她成长过程中的经历，她期望他也是那样。对。所以她在怂恿他。
on. She is glaring at him like, shut the kid up. Jake tells Dwight that he's ugly. Yeah. And then Dwight is horrible. At my prodding, at my prodding, he's horrible. Can I get my mini soap box out again? Because I did not care for this. No, it wasn't good. It bumped me. I didn't like that Dwight told a child, like that Dwight insulted a child the way he did. I didn't, I think we're meant as an audience to be like, yeah, you give it to the jerk kid. But I just, that I didn't like it. I don't think we're meant to do that. You don't think? I don't think so. I think there's part of you that's glad that this kid is at least putting his place a little bit, although done completely and appropriately. But I think what I took away from it is Dwight is a kid.
她瞪着他，仿佛在说“让那小家伙闭嘴”。杰克告诉德怀特他很丑。对。然后德怀特太恶劣了。在我的怂恿下，在我的怂恿下，他太恶劣了。我能再次搬出我的迷你肥皂箱吗？因为我一点也不喜欢这样。不，这不好。这让我感到不舒服。我不喜欢德怀特对一个孩子说那些话——德怀特像那样侮辱一个孩子。我不，我觉得作为观众我们的意思是，是的，给那个混蛋小孩点颜色看看。但我只是，我不喜欢这样。我不认为我们的意思是那样的。你觉得不是吗？我不这么认为。我觉得你心里有一部分会高兴这个小孩至少被收拾了一下，尽管做得完全不合适。但我从中体会到的是，德怀特还是个孩子。
These are two kids in one conversation. I mean, Isabel watched it with me and she was like, oh, mom, Dwight. And I said, I know he's just a kid. Well, it all just made me super sad for Jake. Oh, well, Jake, Jake is doomed. That's what I felt like. He's Meredith's kid and he's doomed. At 15 minutes, 39 seconds, Pam strikes out again. Oh boy. Yeah. Melissa comes over. She's like, you know, I've spent some time with your mom. She's so nice. And Melissa's like, that lady is not my mother. Like you mean Terry? That's my stepmom. Yeah. So now she's like, oh, for two, right? Oh, yeah. Pam's not doing great until Jake comes over. Jake's probably a little wounded by this time. I think he's a little softer around the edges now. Maybe so. And she's like, do you want
这其实是一次对话中的两个孩子。我是说，伊莎贝尔和我一起看的，她当时说，哦，妈妈，德怀特。我说，我知道他只是个孩子。好吧，这一切都让我为杰克感到超级难过。哦，好吧，杰克，杰克注定要完了。这就是我的感觉。他是梅雷迪思的孩子，他注定要完了。在15分39秒，帕姆再次出师不利。哦，天哪。对。梅丽莎过来了。她说，你知道的，我和你妈妈待过一段时间。她太好了。然后梅丽莎就像是——那个女人才不是我妈妈呢。你是说特里？那是我的继母。所以现在她就像是，哦，两次都猜错对吧？哦，是的。帕姆表现得不太好，直到杰克走过来。杰克这时候可能受了点小伤。我觉得他现在棱角没那么分明了，变得稍微温柔了一点。也许吧。然后她问，你想去
to shred some stuff? Your shredder. My shredder, 17 minutes, 50 seconds, everyone. Your shredder that you said, wait, never use. And people were like, oh, I'm getting to my keyboard. Yes. Boy, we got a lot of mail after I said that early on. Yes, Pam does use her shredder with Jake. By the way, I want to say that original shredder did not work. It was inoperable. And I can't remember now if they had to bring in some other shredder. I think there's a reason why there's not a great shot of it is because it doesn't technically match the giant shredder that's always been there. I will say and also in our early years on set, I know we were on a tight budget, right? We were the show that was almost going to get canceled. We were like, it was sort of shoestring budget.
碎点东西吗？你的碎纸机。我的碎纸机，17分50秒，各位。你曾经说、等等、永远不要用的碎纸机。人们当时就说，哦，我要去键盘上敲了。是的。天哪，我那么说之后，我们收到了好多邮件。是的，帕姆确实和杰克一起用了她的碎纸机。顺便说一句，我想说，原本那个碎纸机根本不能用。它是坏的。我现在记不清他们是不是不得不带另一个碎纸机来。我想这就是为什么没有一个很好的它的镜头的原因，因为它在技术上和那个一直都在的巨大碎纸机不匹配。我要说的是，而且在我们刚到片场的头几年里，我知道我们预算很紧，对吧？我们是那部差点被取消的节目。我们就像是——预算非常紧凑。
And a lot of our appliances in the office, if you look really closely, our old used appliances that they would take from like a prop warehouse or other shows. Oh, the copier didn't work at first. And then they wrote that someone uses the copier and they're like, whoa, hold up. We need a copier. That was just decoration. We're planning on using that. And that shredder looked like something from the Dharma Initiative. It looked really old. Well, you remember that copier used to often not work, right? Do you remember that? We were always fixing that copier. All the time. But then when I worked in offices, we were always fixing our copiers. So maybe it worked just as it was meant to work. I don't know.
而且办公室里的很多电器，如果你仔细看的话，都是他们从道具仓库或其他节目里拿来的旧的二手电器。哦，复印机一开始根本不好使。然后他们写到有人使用复印机，他们就说，哦，等等。我们需要一台复印机。那只是装饰品。我们正打算用它呢。而那个碎纸机看起来就像是“达摩计划”里的东西。它看起来真的很旧。好吧，你还记得那台复印机以前经常坏，对吧？你记得吗？我们一直在修理那台复印机。一直都在修。但后来当我在办公室工作时，我们一直在修理我们的复印机。所以也许它本来就该是那样工作的，我不知道。
Or as good as any copier I've ever used. All right. All right. So now Toby goes into Michael's office and he's returning the toys that Sasha took. And Toby asked Michael if he's okay. And Michael says, well, you have to ask me that because you're head of HR and Toby's like, well, it's true. It's true. But how are you? And then they end up having a heart to heart. A sweet heart to heart. Michael and Toby. I know. But of course, then Michael asks if Sasha has a godfather. And Toby's like, she does. Toby actually cuts him off. Yeah. So he's like, hey, does Sasha have a godfather? Because he does. He does. She does. She does. Oh, right. Yeah. But Michael decides he's gotten,
或者和任何我用过的复印机一样好。好吧。好吧。所以现在托比走进了迈克尔的办公室，他把萨莎拿走的玩具还了回去。托比问迈克尔他没事吧。迈克尔说，好吧，你必须这么问我，因为你是人事主管。托比说，嗯，确实如此。确实如此。但你还好吗？然后他们最终进行了一场倾心交谈。一场温馨的交谈。迈克尔和托比。我知道。但当然，接着迈克尔问萨莎有没有教父。托比就像是——托比直接打断了他。对。所以他就像是，嘿，萨莎有教父吗？因为他有。他有。她有。她有。哦，对。对。但迈克尔决定他已经，
he's feeling a little better. He's going to sign up for an online dating service. He's going to get out there. He is. He's going to try to make little Michael Scott's dream come true. Let's get married and have his 100 kids. And he wants the ladies out there to know how serious he is about having a family and his love of children. So he makes his username little kid lover. Yeah. He's going to do it. Oh boy. All right. So now huge bombshell. Abby is leaving with Kevin and she wants to invite Jim over for dinner. Very sweet. He can't. He has plans. He has plans. What plans Kevin says. You never have plans. Guess what guys? Jim has a date. Jim has a date. With who? Is this maybe Brenda? Is Brenda back?
他感觉好多了。他打算注册一个在线交友服务。他要走出去。他会的。他要努力实现小迈克尔·斯科特的梦想。让我们结婚并生下一百个孩子吧。他想让外面的女士们知道他对组建家庭和对孩子的热爱有多么认真。所以他把用户名取为小男孩爱好者。是的。他要这么做了。天哪。好吧。那么现在有个重磅消息。艾比要和凯文一起走了，她想邀请吉姆去吃晚饭。非常贴心。他去不了。他有安排。他有安排。有什么安排，凯文说。你从来没有安排。你猜怎么着，伙计们？吉姆有个约会。吉姆有个约会。和谁？这人可能是布伦达吗？布伦达回来了吗？
Fan question. Laura Dini would like to know who is Jim going on a date with? I don't know. Brenda? Is he lying? No, he has a date. No, he has a date. I think he does. No, he for sure has a date. Yeah. So then we get to the last scene of the episode. This is the second time I cried in this episode. When they were singing? Yeah. Jenna. Dwight is playing guitar. I get the first one. Why did you cry in this one? I don't know. This song really gets to me. Teach your children. Michael is singing. Crosby, Stills and Nash. Yeah. And Young, I guess. I love how, um, I love how Steve does this. He went for it. He went for it. His very weird harmony, falsetto. Yeah. Yeah. And during this scene, Jim and Pam have a little banter, little banter. This was a real
粉丝提问。劳拉·迪尼想知道吉姆要去和谁约会？我不知道。布伦达？他在撒谎吗？不，他有个约会。不，他确实有个约会。我想他是有的。不，他肯定有约会。好吧。然后我们来到了这一集的最后一个场景。这是我在这集中第二次哭了。当他们在唱歌的时候？是的。珍娜。德怀特在弹吉他。我懂第一次。你为什么在这个地方哭了？我不知道。这首歌真的很触动我。教教你们的孩子。迈克尔在唱歌。克罗斯比、斯蒂尔斯和纳什。是的。还有杨，我猜。我喜欢，嗯，我喜欢史蒂夫这样做。他全力以赴了。他真的豁出去了。他那非常奇怪的和声、假声。是的。是的。在这个场景中，吉姆和帕姆有一点调侃，一点调侃。这真是
kick in the nuts for Pam. This was a tough one. Jim says, why does he have a guitar if he never plays it? They're doing their thing where they kind of flirt and shitty chat in the corner. Exactly. They're commenting on what's happening. But then, uh, they kind of giggle. Then Pam looks away and she turns back and she's like, well, my theory is he's gone. Jim's gone. Oh, yeah. And then your little adjustment after you realize you were talking to no one and he's gone is so great because you kind of feel her like, oh, okay. Jeez. So at 19 minutes, one second, we sort of start this montage, right? Jim is leaving. Yeah. And you see this really sweet thing with Michael and Sasha. Like he's kind of helping, I think, get her in Toby's car. And then you end
对帕姆狠狠的一击。这一幕真难受。吉姆说，他从来不弹吉他，为什么还要留着它？他们在做他们拿手的事，在角落里调情和瞎扯。没错。他们在评论正在发生的事情。但随后，嗯，他们咯咯笑了起来。然后帕姆把视线移开，接着她转过头说，好吧，我的理论是他走了。吉姆走了。哦，是的。然后你发现自己是在对着空气说话、吉姆已经不在了之后，你做出的那个小调整太棒了，因为你能感觉到你那种“哦，好吧。天哪”的心情。所以在大约19分1秒，我们开始了这段蒙太奇，对吧？吉姆要走了。是的。然后你会看到迈克尔和萨莎之间一个非常温馨的画面。就像他在帮忙，我想是送她上托比的车。然后你以
with this Dwight talking head. Yeah. It's so good. What? Okay. I have a question. Yeah. Where is that photo from? I found out. Good. I was hoping you would. Yeah. So during this talking head, Dwight is kind of explaining the value of children in the shrewt ancestry. And there is this photo, this black and white photo of a family, seemingly kind of impoverished family. Impoverished family. Well, Dwight says that they would have a lot of children so they could work the fields, which, you know, is not a real stretch because my mom grew up in rural Texas on a farm and she had their 12 siblings. Yeah. They all worked the farm. I think that was a thing. Yeah. That was a thing. Yeah. Life on the prairie, little house on the prairie. We learned that from little house on
德怀特的访谈结束。是的。太棒了。什么？好吧。我有个问题。是的。那张照片是从哪来的？我查到了。太好了。我希望你能查到。是的。所以在这次访谈中，德怀特正在解释在施鲁特家族的血统中孩子们的价值。有一张照片，这张黑白照片是一个家庭，看起来像是某种比较贫困的家庭。贫困的家庭。嗯，德怀特说他们会生很多孩子，这样他们就可以下地干活，你知道的，这其实并不离谱，因为我妈妈就是在德克萨斯州农村的一个农场长大的，她有12个兄弟姐妹。是的。他们都在农场干活。我想这曾经很常见。是的。这很常见。是的。草原生活，草原小屋。我们是从《草原小屋》里
the prairie. Not really. But that family had a lot of kids and they all worked that field and farm. They had like four. I think they had more than that. Five. I feel like it was upwards of seven. What? Mara. Mara. Mary. Half pint. Yeah. The baby who I think died on Christmas Eve of fever. There were some boys. One boy. Maybe there were only four or five. I don't know. They all worked the farm though. Anyway, Dwight also says that they sometimes ate the weakest person in times of real hardship. And then he was like, but not a kid. We didn't eat the babies. But the way he says it means like maybe sometimes they did. Well, no, he said, I'm kidding. We never ate the children. It never came to that. Right. But if it did, they were, yeah. All right. Well, at 20 minutes, 17
了解到的。其实也不是。但那个家庭有很多孩子，他们都在田里和农场干活。他们大概有四个。我觉得他们比那还多。五个。我觉得至少有七个。什么？玛拉。玛拉。玛丽。小不点。是的。那个好像在圣诞前夜发烧死去的婴儿。还有一些男孩。一个男孩。也许只有四个或五个。我不知道。不过他们都在农场干活。不管怎样，德怀特还说，在真正困难的时候，他们有时会吃掉最弱小的人。然后他说，但小孩子除外。我们不吃婴儿。但他说话的方式听起来好像有时他们确实吃过。好吧，不，他说，我开玩笑的。我们从来没有吃过孩子。还没到那种地步。好吧。但如果真的到了那一步，他们，是的。好吧，在20分17
seconds, there is a shot of this photo. And in the Boost Crews podcast, we mentioned that Rain did bring in a number of photos of his real family. Is this one? No. Oh. It's not. There was a real photo of his family in the vending machine in the cold open of Boost Crews. But this was not Rain's real family. Kent told me that they just found it on Getty Images. It's a stock photo. They just licensed it and it became the lore of Dwight's family right there. Just a picture. There you go. It's somebody's family. It's someone's family. Maybe someone will write in and say, hey, those are my ancestors. Those are my ancestors. A Getty Image photographer came to a reunion in 1814. Yeah. Anyway. All right. Well, here you go. That's our episode. All right,
秒，镜头切到了这张照片。在《Boost Crews》播客中，我们提到雷恩确实带了许多他自己真人的家庭照片。这张是吗？不是。哦。不是的。在《Boost Crews》开场时，自动售货机里确实有他家人的真实照片。但这并不是雷恩真正的家人。肯特告诉我，他们只是在盖蒂图片社（Getty Images）上找到了这张照片。这是一张库存照片。他们只是买下了版权，然后这就成了德怀特家族的历史了。就只是一张照片。你看。这是某个人的家庭。是某人的家庭。也许会有人写信来说，嘿，那是我的祖先。那是我的祖先。一个盖蒂图片社的摄影师在1814年参加了一个家庭聚会。是的。不管怎样。好吧。好了，这就是我们这一集的全部内容。好吧，
you guys, let's take your daughter to work day. If you have any questions, if we left anything out, write us in and we will see you next week. We will, I think, for Michael's birthday. Michael's birthday. Yeah, the ice skating rink. Oh, I have good photos from that one. I have good stories. Mm. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com.
各位，我们去“带女儿上班日”吧。如果你有任何问题，或者我们漏掉了什么，请写信给我们，我们下周见。我想我们会聊迈克尔的生日。迈克尔的生日。是的，溜冰场。哦，我那里有好照片。我有好故事。嗯。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）共同制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮弗（Sam Peefer）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听该节目的无广告版本以及我们的彩蛋节目《Candy Bag》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需免费试用 StitcherPremium 一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。